bien bonsoir à toutes et à tous nous
reprenons donc nos travaux après
l'audition de Ségolène Royal par
l'audition de Madame Dominique voannet
vous êtes ancienne ministre de
l'Aménagement du Territoire et de
l'Environnement et nous vous remercions
très sincèrement d'avoir accepté de
répondre à notre invitation
madame la ministre nous connaissons les
circonstances qui expliquent les report
de votre audition nous vous remercions
d'être présente ce soir et nous
comprenons parfaitement les raisons qui
ont conduit à ce décalage nous avons
auditionné la semaine dernière Monsieur
Lionel Jospin qui dirigeait le
gouvernement auquel vous avez appartenu
comme ministre de l'Aménagement du
Territoire et de l'Environnement de 1997
à 2001
le décret du 16 juin 1997 relatif à vos
attributions comporte au regard des
préoccupations de la commission
d'enquête trois domaines d'intérêt la
préservation de la qualité de l'air et
la lutte contre l'effet de serre la
politique en matière de sûreté nucléaire
y compris ce qui concerne le transport
des matières radioactives et difficiles
à usage civil compétences que vous
partagiez avec le ministre de l'économie
des finances et de l'industrie ainsi que
la détermination et la mise en oeuvre de
la politique d'utilisation rationnelle
des ressources énergétiques et de
développement des énergies renouvelables
auxquelles vous étiez selon ce décret
associé
au niveau européen en 2001 était adopté
une directive relative à la promotion de
l'électricité produite à partir de
sources d'énergie renouvelables sur le
marché intérieur de l'électricité qui a
dû être négocié alors que vous étiez en
fonction
comme vous le savez les conditions de la
fermeture de Superphénix sont suscités
diverses observations et commères
commentaires de la part des personnes
qui ont déjà été auditionnées par notre
commission mettant en évidence la
frontière ténue qui peut exister entre
un outil de recherche et un moyen de
production sans parler des différentes
appréciations pourtant sur l'abandon
d'un axe de recherche ou d'une filière
industrielle même potentielle voilà je
vais pas être plus long et après ces
quelques mots de contexte
je vais vous laisser la parole après
vous avoir en vertu de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
demander de bien vouloir prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité et
rien que la vérité je vous invite donc
Madame la Ministre de la main droite et
dire je le jure et madame la ministre je
vous laisse donc la parole pour un
propos liminaire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés mesdames et messieurs je réponds
bien naturellement à votre convocation
c'est d'ailleurs une obligation
sans arriver à me départir de quelques
questionnements quel est l'objet réel de
la commission d'enquête
s'agit-il d'éclairer les choix du
gouvernement et du Parlement dans une
période marquée par des difficultés
persistantes de la France à respecter
ses engagements s'agissant de la lutte
contre l'effet de serre et le changement
climatique qui en résulte et par de
fortes tensions sur le marché de
l'énergie liée à la guerre en Ukraine
notamment il semblerait que cette
première hypothèse soit une fausse piste
puisqu'à l'heure où vous rendrez votre
rapport les grands choix auront été
faits la loi relative à l'accélération
de la production d'énergie renouvelable
a été votée définitivement le 31 janvier
le projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération des procédures liées à la
construction de nouvelles centrales
nucléaires à proximité des sites
existants
déjà adopté par le Sénat en première
lecture vous aura été soumis et un
Conseil de politique nucléaire dont je
ne connais pas la composition ni le
statut et pour cause puisque
contrairement au contraire de défense
défini par l'article 15 de la
Constitution il n'est pas défini
je pourrais pour plaisanter dire que
c'est une sorte de machin Haddock ça ne
serait pas correct mais ça me laisse à
penser en tout cas que les décisions ne
seront pas prises totalement au
Parlement la CNDP connaît d'ailleurs en
ce moment même un questionnement
analogue puisque le débat public sur le
nucléaire qu'elle porte n'est pas
terminée alors que les décisions qui
engagent notre pays pour des décennies
sont déjà prises les associations en ont
il y a quelques jours claquer la porte
s'agit-il deuxième hypothèse d'établir
les responsabilités des uns et des
autres dans les choix énergétiques de
notre pays ou même de désigner des
bouquets mystères des choix parfois
discutables qui ont été faits dans le
passé je pense à la frénésie
d'acquisition externe des DF en
ça marche de manœuvre pour l'entretien
et la maintenance je pense au retard à
la mise en œuvre des programmes
d'efficacité et d'économies d'énergie
dans le bâtiment le tertiaire les
transports et j'en passe
à quelle échéance allons-nous remonter
au choc pétrolier 73 74 ou allons-nous
comme le sugerait la résolution pourtant
création de la commission d'enquête nous
concentrer sur les 10 dernières années
je ne sais pas exactement quoi qu'il en
soit j'ai bien l'intention effectivement
de répondre à la totalité de vos
questions en avec quelques précautions
néanmoins la première concerne la
dévalorisation du politique par rapport
à la technique
rarement contestée dans ces fondements
même si les choix techniques comme si
les choix techniques n'étaient pas
dictés par des considérations politiques
comme si les techniciens n'étaient pas
également impactés par un climat
politique ou par la commande politique
ça m'a frappé dans des dans des
auditions antérieures moi je me
positionne vraiment dans cette affaire
comme une politique je vais l'expliquer
et le défendre et d'ailleurs je pense
que c'est aussi votre cas vous avez été
élu
pas pour jouer les ingénieurs du
nucléaire mais pour prendre des
décisions politiques et arbitrer de
cette façon
je voulais aussi évoquer les préventions
manifestées envers les Antibes
nucléaires suspects forcément suspect au
choix de peut irrationnelles d'ignorance
d'un conséquence voire de pulsions
antipatriotiques alors que
l'enthousiasme pro-nucléaire les
relations incestueuses entre les
entreprises du secteur et les services
de l'État les moyens et méthodes des
lobbyistes ne sont jamais questionnées
je veux également signaler que je n'ai
plus exercer de responsabilité politique
nationale après 2011 date à laquelle
j'ai quitté le Sénat depuis j'ai exercé
des mandats locaux puis un engagement
professionnel dans le champ des Affaires
sociales et de la santé et j'ai pris ma
retraite il y a un an
alors j'ai prévu effectivement une
intervention limitaire qui va situer
forcément
des choses dont vous avez entendu parler
c'est-à-dire semaine désolé de tout ce
qui pourrait être redondant mais je
pense que la façon dont j'ai résonné
impose que je vous rappelle aussi
comment
j'ai
lu ce qui s'était passé avant ma prise
de responsabilité et les leçons que j'en
ai tiré
vous avez choisi pour établir les
responsabilités des uns et des autres de
remonter 30 ans en arrière ce que vous
me signalez dans le questionnaire que
vous m'avez envoyé vous avez d'ailleurs
auditionné Corinne Lepage qui a été
ministre de l'Environnement avant moi
entre 95 et 97 soit mais les décisions
les plus lourdes ont été prises avant 25
ans avant précisément comment
sommes-nous arrivés là sans remonter à
Mathusalem et aux décisions de
développement d'une filière graphique
gaz dans une grande complicité entre le
nucléaire civil elle nucléaire militaire
complicité qui perdure les décisions qui
nous impactent le plus aujourd'hui ont
été prises dans les années 70 lors des
chocs pétroliers
sur deux champs on n'a pas de pétrole
mais on a des idées et on chasse le
gaspi avec l'Agence française pour les
économies d'énergie et surtout on
investit massivement dans l'énergie
nucléaire Marcel Boiteux alors directeur
général d'EDF raconte dans ses mémoires
comment les choses se sont passées un
jour de descendre 73 un samedi dit-il on
lui demande de faire remonter avant midi
ces propositions gouvernement de combien
de tranches nucléaires EDF a-t-elle
besoin et peut-être construire
il raconte j'ouvre les guillemets à midi
je rappelais couture couture c'est un
secrétaire général à l'énergie de
l'époque pas plus de 6 ou 7 tranches par
an deux tranches étaient prévues pour 74
et il était clair qu'on ne m'engagerait
une troisième
nous nous dit que Jean couture se
prépare à faire un peu de forcing et
aller demander six ou cette tranche pour
qu'on aille au moins à 4 ou 5 4 sans
doute on connaît la suite le plan
Messmer charge EDF d'engager la
construction de 13000 MW entre 72 et 77
puis de 6 à 7 tranches par an ensuite
alors je m'arrête un peu là dessus parce
que Pierre Messmer n'est pas n'importe
qui pierre Esmer a longtemps été
ministre des armées de 1960 à 1969 ça
fait rêver les ministres d'aujourd'hui
une telle longévité et il a mis en place
la force de frappe nucléaire voulue par
le général de Gaulle il est ensuite
Premier ministre entre 72 et 74 et le
plan Messenger est adopté alors que
Georges Pompidou est très malade et
délègue de plus en plus ses
responsabilités il meurt d'ailleurs
quelques jours plus tard
le choix du plan Messmer donc se porte
en rupture avec les décisions
antérieures du général de Gaulle sur la
construction de centrale PVR PWR
standardisé de 900 mégahwatts à l'urine
enrichie sous licence américaine
Schneider Austin house vous connaissez
cette histoire par cœur monsieur le
rapporteur on construit pour les
industriels on recrute on forme
ingénieur et techniciens et on a qu'une
lointaine idée de la suite de la valse
du cycle et du démantèlement notamment
quant au risque il est constamment
minimisé je ne pense pas seulement aux
risques nucléaires je pense aussi au
risque économiques et financiers le fait
par exemple qu'on considère que les
activités nucléaires ne peuvent pas être
rassurées nous sont d'ailleurs pas
assurés est un problème qui date de
cette époque
le plan Messenger est rapidement
contesté dans son ampleur dès 1983 la
commission énergie du Commissariat au
Plan dit que trop de tranches sont
prévues
les conséquences sont connues elles
aussi un endettement massif des DF une
politique d'exportation à bas prix là
encore je m'arrête parce que j'ai
entendu dans cette commission certains
dire mais c'est bien d'exporter c'est la
grandeur de la France d'exporter sauf
que on exportait que le kilowatt-heure
produit en gardant pour nous les lignes
haute tension les déchets les coûts du
démantèlement et les risques
endettement massif politique
d'exportation à bas prix fixation
purement politique du prix du
kilowatt-heure le prix régulier qui ne
tient aucun compte du coût marginal du
kilowatt en période de pointe destiné à
encourager la consommation d'électricité
il faut citer aussi l'escalade que
constitue la décision de construire des
réacteurs de plus en plus puissants via
des licences Westinghouse francisés
annonciatrice de problèmes nouveaux ça
vous aura pas échappé que les problèmes
de corrosion sous contrainte touchent
essentiellement les 1300 MW et les 1450
le choix est politique mais les
conséquences de l'emballement sont
économiques le nucléaire n'est pas
assuré je l'ai déjà dit quand c'est pas
l'état qui paye c'est le contribuable
donc qui assume le risque le coût du
traitement des déchets est sous-évalué
d'abord parce qu'on a aucun inventaire à
cette époque et on avait encore pas en
l'an 2000 d'inventaire donc des
quantités de déchets pour chaque
catégorie d'entre eux
et qu'on n'a pas réellement pensé
aux contraintes et au coût de l'aval du
cycle on prend des décisions à la louche
des décisions qu'il a encore sont
purement politique c'est le cas par
exemple pour les provisions CGOS n'y
reviendra l'endroit propose 35 milliards
d'euros la SN dit 48 et Ségolène Royal
tranche à 25 sur quelle base pourquoi
personne ne sait l'expliquer on n'a pas
non plus intégré le coût du
démantèlement des central qui est aussi
sous-évalué d'après la Cour des comptes
qui souligne qu'on provisionne en France
à peu près un tiers de ce que provisions
de l'Allemagne
alors vous allez me dire pourquoi
rappeler tout ça mais parce que
évidemment ça fait partie du contexte
dans lequel j'ai travaillé ça explique
aussi certaines des préoccupations de
l'époque mais je vais pour répondre à
vos questions me concentrer sur le thème
même de votre commission vous évoquez
la perte de souveraineté et
d'indépendance énergétique de la France
je ne suis pas d'accord avec votre a
priori de départ la souveraineté
nationale désigne la capacité d'un État
à prendre ses propres décisions de façon
indépendante c'est un des principes
essentiels de notre Constitution
l'article 3 dit la souveraineté
nationale appartient au peuple qu'il
exerce il y a ces représentants élus ou
via référendum on admet évidemment que
la souveraineté puisse être limitée par
des engagements internationaux notamment
européens à ma connaissance aucun État
étranger aucune institution
multilatérale ne nous impose nos propres
choix en matière énergétique la question
de notre souveraineté ne me paraît pas
réellement posée
s'agissant de la dépense énergétique je
ne crois pas non plus qu'il y a eu une
évolution récente qui justifie une
commission d'enquête la plupart des
choix ou des non choix de notre
politique énergétique ont été
historiquement justifiées par cette
revendication qui tient plus du mantra
que des faits car l'indépendance
énergétique n'existe pas et n'a jamais
existé au cours de la période qui vous
intéresse vous ne faites pas la
confusion si banale qu'elle a pollué le
débat organisé entre les deux candidats
présents au second tour de la
présidentielle de 2007 entre énergie et
électricité mais si c'est le cas vous
mesurez le poids des énergies fossiles
dans notre mix énergétique de l'ordre de
70% exclusivement importés
il s'agit de pétrole pour plus de 60% de
gaz d'électricité ensuite pour 25% dont
70% et d'origine nucléaires dans ce
domaine l'indépendance énergétique est
pratiquement nulle on achète la totalité
de notre uranium naturel
on a acheté les technologies qui nous
permettaient effectivement de produire
d'installer nos centrales on a besoin de
nombreux partenaires pour le traitement
des déchets et on a des relations
extrêmement préoccupantes avec la Russie
notamment sur ce terrain
si on parle d'un dépense énergétique
seuls les renouvelables pour 10 à 15% à
peine du tel peuvent être considérés
comme contribué à la dépense énergétique
de la France et encore les panneaux
solaires depuis le torpillage de la
filière française elle est pas le
d'éoliennes sont largement importantes
nous sommes dans une situation
ubuesque le problème le plus grave
auquel nous sommes confrontés et celui
de notre dépendance pathologique au
combustible fossiles et on en parle à
peine
conséquence logique de cette impensée
collective nous sommes évidemment
incapables de prendre des décisions qui
pourraient permettre d'engager le
sevrage collectif ou au moins d'envoyer
les bons signaux aux usagers et aux
consommateurs s'agissant par exemple de
la généralisation des SUV pour les
voitures ou de la capacité à réguler le
secteur aérien notamment privé
pendant ce temps de quoi parle-t-on de
l'électricité 25% du total donc et du
nucléaire et encore du nucléaire qui ne
représente aujourd'hui que 17% de notre
problème
pi on en parle d'une façon caricaturale
qui confine à la désinformation comment
qualifier autrement le fait d'établir
sans argumenter un lien de cause à effet
entre la décision de fermer les deux
tranches de Fessenheim après 42 années
de vie et je cite le risque d'exposition
à des coupures d'électricité qui semble
inévitable
comme s'il n'était pas acquis que les
causes principales sont à rechercher du
côté de l'indisponibilité de 32 des 56
réacteurs en début d'hiver et de la
guerre en Ukraine
alors évidemment on va y revenir
longuement si on veut garantir la
souveraineté de la France et améliorer
sa médiocre indépendance énergétique il
va falloir mettre en oeuvre une
stratégie globale et cohérente qui a
ceci une forte réduction des
consommations individuelle et collective
mobilisant tous les secteurs d'activité
l'industrie les transports l'agriculture
le dessert l'habitat et les ménages je
reviendrai en combinant efficacité
énergétique et économie d'énergie une
diversification des sources d'énergie
afin d'utiliser chaque source d'énergie
pour ce qu'elle fait le mieux pour être
clair c'est totalement inefficace de
transformer de la vapeur de la chaleur
donc on électricité pour la
retransformer en chaleur dans des
radiateurs électriques avec dans le mix
énergétique lors de la diversification
de moins en moins de fossiles et de plus
en plus
et puis de façon plus générale une
poursuite des efforts d'efficacité
énergétique je crois que l'indépendance
énergique de la France ça peut pas être
juste une tête de chapitre un mot
magique il n'y a pas de Yaka faucon il
faut balayer toutes les activités
humaines et mettre en place des bouquets
de solutions combinées en pensant toutes
les étapes de la chaîne les outils
d'incitation et dissuasion les
co-conditionnalités des subventions est
direct les études et conseils et aussi
c'est aujourd'hui le parent pauvre la
formation des professionnels existants
et à venir et la disponibilité des
matériaux et équipements cette exercice
que ce sont attelés les parlementaires
en 2015 avec la loi LTE pour la
croissance verte terme qui ne veut pas
dire grand-chose qui fixe des objectifs
clairs de réduction de consommation
individuelle et collective dans ces
articles elle 101 à l104
alors évidemment j'ai suivi la polémique
des dernières semaines sur cette
question est-ce qu'on est toujours sur
-50% en 2050 par rapport à 2012 la
ministre 10 - 40 on ne sait pas
exactement c'est fâcheux mais j'aurais
envie de vous dire qu'importe puisque
l'essentiel me paraît être de s'engager
enfin dans l'action sur la base d'une
analyse correcte de la situation
et nous en invoquant des solutions
magiques coûteuses et lointaines de
mobiliser tous les outils qui doivent
l'être d'avoir de la ténacité et la
continuité dans l'action publique sur
des politiques très lourdes comme la
lutte contre l'étalement urbain
l'élimination ou la remédiation des
passoires thermiques ou les
constructions neuves à la fois dans
l'habitat et dans le tertiaire quand on
construit c'est pour 100 ans l'inertie
et considérable
alors
je vais évidemment rentrer de façon plus
précise dans le vif du sujet pour
répondre à votre première question
puisque votre première question elle me
demande en fait
qu'elle regarde je porte sur la séquence
qui vient de s'écouler au cours des 30
ans passés puis on en viendra dans la
des questions suivantes à mon propre
travail et à mes propres responsabilités
mais au fond le raisonnement auquel vous
me proposez de me prêter n'est pas très
différente celui qui a été le mien que
je suis arrivé au responsabilités
c'est-à-dire que effectivement le sujet
numéro un c'est d'objectiver les
confrontés et de faire en sorte de ne
jamais se contenter d'une solution on
n'a pas le choix madame la ministre pour
vous faire apposer votre signature en
bas d'un texte préparé par les services
mais chaque fois qu'une question se pose
d'examiner les avantages et les
inconvénients de plusieurs hypothèses
c'est rare qui est une solution un
problème et si on s'est laissé mettre la
tête dans la seringue dans l'entonnoir
au point d'en avoir plus le choix c'est
soit qu'il y a une catastrophe
inattendue soit qu'on fait mal son
travail
alors qu'en est-il de l'électricité qui
ne représente on l'a dit que 25% du
total notre consommation d'énergie
moi je trouve très intéressant de voir
comment on utilise l'électricité
aujourd'hui on utilise que 3 % dans les
transports y compris le TGV on utilise
2% de l'agriculture
25% dans l'industrie et 70% dans le
résidentiel c'est des chiffres qui sont
souvent sous-estimés y compris par les
consommateurs qui disent mais on a marre
qu'on nous demande de faire des efforts
alors qu'on en demande pas forcément
l'industrie d'abord c'est inexact et
deuxièmement ça s'explique la moitié de
cette consommation correspond au
chauffage électrique on l'a dit j'ai
entendu plusieurs de vos auditions au
cours desquelles le débat a eu lieu sur
la pointe la surpointes etc bon on est
bien d'accord que des pointes de
consommation il y en a tous les jours
trois heures le matin 3h le soir à peu
près mais on parle bien de la surpote en
cas de pic de froid en France donc la
moitié de la en Europe la moitié de la
surpoine serait liée au choix français
du chauffage électrique donc la moitié
de consommation
résidentielle c'est du chauffage
électrique et l'autre moitié des usages
spécifiques hors chauffage l'éclairage
électroménager l'audiovisuel
l'informatique
la production d'électricité on l'a dit
tout à l'heure et largement assurée par
le nucléaire 65 à 70%
quand sera-t-il demain il y a un grand
discussion et on sera peut-être amené à
revenir par le fil de vos questions sur
la question de savoir si on est amené à
électrifier beaucoup d'usage pour
réduire les émissions de carbone
ce qui m'a paraît en tout cas important
c'est que on ne peut pas se projeter sur
la période qui vient
sans prendre en compte des innovations
et des préoccupations qui n'existaient
pas au moment où nous avons pris nos
principales décisions entre 97 et 2001
mon appréciation sur la politique
énergie la situation énergétique de la
France à l'heure d'aujourd'hui elle est
quand même assez sévère je trouve que
très peu a été fait depuis un quart de
siècle pour réduire notre dépendance au
pétrole pour améliorer l'efficacité en
utilisant les meilleures technologies
disponibles pour réduire les
consommations débiles on a laissé faire
l'offre et la demande tirée par le
marketing et la publicité on dispose
toujours pas de plan climat régionaux
avec un volet de formation permettant
d'avoir des chauffagistes des
énergéticiens des artisans du bâtiment
indispensables pour assurer la
transition
la rente du nucléaire a été dilapidée
via des tarifs absurdement bas
encourageantes gaspillage et une
politique frénétique d'acquisition
hasardeuse à l'export sans compter la
politique de vente de centrales aussi au
bilan discutable je pense à Daya B en
Chine ou malheureusement à discutable au
kilos
on va devoir financer au-delà du grand
carénage 50 milliards d'euros de EDF 100
milliards d'euros dit la Cour des
comptes le démantèlement
simultané de dizaines de tranches là où
les solutions retenues pour les déchets
d'aujourd'hui et de demain la
construction de nouveaux outils de
production et si vous confirmez votre
choix d'une nouvelle génération de
centrale
les alternatives renouvelables
évidemment et je ne parle même pas des
INDs les sites militaires de Cadarache
du Marcoule de Valduc dont on ne sait à
peu près rien moi si j'étais
parlementaire aujourd'hui je poserai des
questions et jeudisnerai sur la masse de
déchets nucléaires accumulée sur ces
sites
sur la nature des contrats qui sont
signés avec des partenaires étrangers
pour voir si ça tient la route
il me semble que le choix d'une
nucléaire nous expose à des risques
longtemps sous-estimés et j'aimerais ne
pas être caricaturé en froussardes parce
que la peur n'a rien à voir là-dedans
et on n'est pas enfin je ne suis pas
hostile à ces choix parce que j'ai peur
d'avoir peur comme le dit de façon
insultante la BD à la mode mais parce
que je considère que les risques
économiques et financiers d'abord les
risques environnementaux et sanitaires
ensuite les risques pour notre sécurité
collective dans une période de
terrorisme et de
tension internationale enfin sont
considérables ils sont liés confrontés à
des impasses financières nous pourrions
être amenés à arbitrer entre sûreté et
production ou à relâcher les efforts de
maintenance ou relâcher nos efforts ou
nos moyens sur la surveillance de
certains sites
je vais pas être plus long pour
l'instant sur les questions nucléaires
je note quand même puisque c'est un
point sur lesquels vous avez aussi
interrogé pas mal d'interlocuteurs que
les problèmes s'accumulent les déboires
de Melox la corrosion des évaporateurs
de l'usine de La Hague la détection de
problèmes de corrosion sous contrainte
dans la tuyauterie du circuit de secours
de certains réacteur les plus gros on
l'a dit EDF nous dit c'était
imprévisible sans doute je considère
pour ma part ce n'était pas un manque
d'entretien mais plutôt à défaut
générique dont on a d'ailleurs pas
trouvé la cause
j'apprendrai d'ailleurs bien après mon
départ du gouvernement
car nianderie Claude Lacoste qui était
directeur de la sûreté ni Christian
Piret ministre de l'Industrie de
l'époque n'avait jugé nécessaire
d'informer la ministre correspondance de
la sûreté qu'on a procédé en 98 et 99 à
l'arrêt successive de tous les réacteurs
pour remplacer à l'identique les
tronçons fissurées au de reproduire le
problème donc pas un problème de
maintenance maintenant cela a été faite
l'entretien a été fait mais un problème
de conception et un problème de contrôle
aussi et ensuite un problème de fuite en
avant en France
la France est le seul pays au monde
avoir fait le choix de réacteur de plus
en plus puissant ou Sting house s'est
redescendu à 1000 MW l'effet de taille
français posent des proliminésies on l'a
dit
chez nous mais aussi dans ce qu'on a
vendu à l'étranger
1650 MW au kilo auto 1735 à Taishan et
puis évidemment le passage à mon avis
trop rapide de Phoenix à super Phénix de
250 MW à 1220
et puis évidemment je ne commente pas la
décision de commencer de commander 14
paires de plus alors que le prototype à
10 ans de retard coûtera 5 à 6 fois le
prix envisagé initialement et ne
fonctionne pas alors
s'agissant de vos questions
excusez-moi faut pas que je me
je perds mes
documents oui donc je pense que ce que
je viens de vous dire répond plus ou
moins
aux premières questions sur mon
évaluation de la situation énergétique
de la France vous me demandez ensuite de
préciser
comment le processus décisionnel
a été
[Musique]
avait lieu alors que j'étais membre du
gouvernement et je souhaite pour ce qui
concerne ce point là vous en dire un
petit peu plus sur la façon dont on
travaille on décide au sein d'un
gouvernement
j'ai trop de papier évidemment
mais je vais retrouver
parce que ça me paraît vraiment
important de rappeler qu'un ministre y
compris dans le champ défini par son
décret d'attribution de décide pas seul
mais j'ai envie aussi de vous dire
quelques mots de la façon dont les
choses se sont passées dans le contexte
politique de l'époque
je tombe sur mon dossier super fini ce
qui va évidemment vous intéresser
beaucoup tout à l'heure
que je fais
j'ai pas mal de papiers parce que sur
chaque des points que j'aborde je me
suis permis de
je me suis permis d'écrire de réunir
toutes les pièces qui permettent de
prouver ce que je suis en train de dire
en fait
non
quand il a trop c'est comme si on
n'avait pas si c'est bon
je suis rentré au gouvernement donc
début juin 1997
sur proposition de Lionel Jospin avec
les responsabilités de ministres de
l'Aménagement du Territoire et de
l'Environnement vous avez évoqué à
plusieurs reprises dans des auditions
l'accord politique vert PS un accord
dont je dois dire aujourd'hui qu'il
était très incomplet puisque nous avons
été surpris en pleine négociation de cet
accord par la dissolution de l'Assemblée
nationale dans des conditions que je ne
rappelle pas cet accord est assez
succinct je ne sais pas si vous l'avez
retrouvé si quelqu'un vous la cité déjà
il prévoit alors j'ouvre les guillemets
de réorienter la politique énergétique
en instaurant un moratoire sur la
construction de réacteurs nucléaires et
sur la fabrication du MOX jusqu'en 2010
tout en augmentant fortement les crédits
pour les économies d'énergie et les
énergies renouvelables cette politique
passe notamment par la fermeture de
super Phénix la réversibilité du
stockage nucléaire en rééquilibrant les
crédits de recherche par application
réelle de la loi Bataille le
retraitement à l'axe sera revu ce qui
suppose une surveillance accrue du site
et un nouvel effort de recherche en
outre aucun nouveau contrat de
retraitement ne sera souscrit le vote
d'une loi sur l'énergie aura lieu au
plus tard en 2005
mon décret d'attribution que vous avez
bien voulu rappeler tout à l'heure me
donner des responsabilités dans une
partie seulement du champ mais pas sur
ce qui concernait effectivement la
production même où la politique
énergétique
c'est plutôt d'ailleurs au titre de la
politique d'aménagement du territoire en
ce que j'ai été amené à porter une loi
de rotation pour l'aménagement et le
développement durable du territoire
d'une part et à piloter le contenu des
contrats de plan que j'ai été amené un
peu à la marche peut-être à revenir sur
les choix énergétiques
mon équipe n'était pas une équipe de
militants vêtus de peau de bêtes
s'éclairant à la bougie dans des
cavernes
l'équipe qui pilotait le champ de
l'énergie était composé de Patrick
fragman ingénieur des mines actuellement
président et CIO de whistinghouse
électrique company de Bernard laponge
polytechnicien et docteur essence
docteur en physique des réacteurs
nucléaires ancien du CEA ancien patron
de la FME animateur aujourd'hui de
Global Chance et de Raymond quinte
ingénieur des mines qui a ensuite piloté
l'INERIS
alors comment avons-nous travaillé d'un
côté les termes d'un accord politique
que je me suis efforcé de respecter et
de faire respecter de l'autre mon décret
d'attribution qui cadrait précisément
mon champ de compétence et d'action et
bien sûr les événements qui se mêlent
après semaine n'ont pas été prévus et
doivent pourtant être gérés en
interministériel souvent ça concernait
peu le nucléaire assez rarement
nucléaire qui représentait à peu près je
pense 10 à 15% de mon activité maximum
ministre antinucléaires dans un
gouvernement qui ne l'était pas je crois
avoir pourtant gagné la confiance et le
respect du Premier ministre et de mes
partenaires au sein du gouvernement
grâce au respect d'une méthode simple
que je n'ai pas impulsée qui a été
décidé par une Jospin qui me convenait
très bien qui a permis de faire vivre la
majorité pluriel d'alors
liberté de parole avant toute décision
puis arbitrage qui s'impose à tous j'ai
souvent plaidé contre des solutions qui
ont fini par être retenues mais je
pouvais les assumer parce que mes
arguments avaient été entendus et pris
au sérieux
je précise d'ailleurs que j'ai beaucoup
échangé spin pendant ces années on se
voyait dans le cadre de mes fonctions
ministérielles une fois toutes les deux
semaines pour aborder les dossiers
d'actualité
du coup j'ai
identifié trois champs sur lesquels ma
légitimité n'a jamais été discuté et sur
lesquels le Premier ministre m'a
toujours soutenu
le travail pour une plus grande
transparence ce qui supposait je
reviendrai que j'ai moi-même accès à
l'information la sûreté des
installations et des activités y compris
les transports vous aurez noté que dans
mon décret d'attribution on précise que
chez en charge de la sûreté des
transports
parce que c'était à l'époque un sujet
très très polémique et qui avait
énormément de contamination qu'on voit
qui posait problème lors des
exportations à l'étranger et puis la
radioprotection des salariés qui est à
l'époque de la responsabilité du
ministère du travail mais dont en fait
aucune institution de s'occuper vraiment
puis je rajouterais bien sûr le respect
des règles et des lois quand je pense au
rejet en mer de l'usine de retraitement
de lag qui suscitait la colère des
Normands comme des Anglais ou à la
contamination des wagons je viens de
citer
deuxième élément de la méthode nous
étions invités à la collégalité alors on
n'est pas chez les bisounours ça a tout
n'a pas toujours été facile chacun était
dans son rôle et ça peut générer des
tensions le ministre de l'Industrie
défend des entreprises et la production
la ministre de l'Environnement défend
d'autres intérêts d'intérêt en général
de des milieux ou des espèces qui ne
votent pas alors comment ça s'est passé
on sait toujours parler tant avec
Dominique Strauss-Kahn qu'avec Christian
Piret on ne parle d'ailleurs pas que du
nucléaire je suis en charge par exemple
la tutelle des installations classées et
ça il y a une interface très importante
avec l'industrie mais on parle aussi de
nucléaire et on va organiser plusieurs
séminaires de travailler avec nos
équipes je pense par exemple à un
séminaire sur une journée entière à
Champs-sur-Marne qui nous permet de
prendre des décisions communes sur cette
un dossier ou en quête des accords
d'identifier précisément quels sont les
désaccords avec le souci de les réduire
Christian pieren n'a pas activement
cherché à me marginaliser mais il était
Sourcieux quand on respecte ses
prérogatives et compétences propres en
cas d'incident ou prit en flagrant délit
de mensonge par omission par exemple les
dirigeants des entreprises du secteur
nucléaire se sont plus spontanément
tournés vers lui que vers moi en
espérant une écoute indulgente ou une
alliance contre le ministère de
l'Environnement ça a été aussi la
spécialité de André Claude Lacoste qui
dirigeait la direction de la sûreté
nucléaire à l'époque
Andric Claude Lacoste une fois m'a dit
de façon assez ça peut ça peut
apparaître drôle sur du coup ça m'a pas
semblé drôle mais il me dit ah vous
savez madame la ministre quand on a
plusieurs tutelles c'est comme si on
avait aucune sous-entendu je fais bien
ce que je veux
[Musique]
et je et si je t'ai parlé avec mes
chocolats je pense qu'il nous aurait
prévenu personne ni l'industrie ni
l'environnement
c'était un petit peu la
culture de l'époque
évidemment mais j'ai bien eu le
sentiment qu'ils étaient pris dans
surprise et pas heureux de l'être voilà
alors ça s'est produit à plusieurs
reprises
que l'industrie choisisse
de privilégier les intérêts de la
production plutôt qu'ils intérêts de la
sûreté
je ne suis pas en état dans de porter
jugements sur chacune de ces affaires je
le comprends il y a par exemple
l'affaire des fissures de l'enceinte de
confinement de Belleville en 1998 ou ce
qui m'agace plus que tout ça n'est pas
tant les fissures qui ne posent pas de
réelles problèmes de sûreté c'est le
fait qu'il est fêter au courant depuis
des années avait été mise en demeure par
l'Autorité de sûreté de l'époque de
procéder aux travaux ne l'avait pas fait
ce qui m'agacait c'était qu'on continue
à les laisser fonctionner sans leur
mettre le couteau sur la gorge pour
qu'il fasse enfin les travaux
le Premier ministre a décidé que on
allait laisser belles villes fonctionner
j'en ai pas fait une affaire
je pense aussi à une visite à
Flamanville qui a été extraordinaire
pour moi
je demande à ce qu'on puisse visiter
cette centrale et échanger avec des
agents dans cette centrale avec été
repéré des relâchements humains des
procédures de sûreté et en fait j'arrive
dans la centrale je trouve qu'il y a
énormément de monde il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de monde qui est là et on me
dit oui on a invité les élus locaux et
puis des camarades qui voulaient visiter
la centrale etc on va faire plusieurs
groupes madame la ministre un pour
visiter parce que
ce serait pas très pratique si on était
trop nombreux donc je me retrouve un
petit peu entouré de costume gris
cravate de la même couleur pour visiter
la centrale et au moment de rentrer dans
la salle vous avez de la chance ou une
cravate rouge monsieur voilà et c'est
l'uniforme comme des ingénieurs du
nucléaire de l'époque voilà et donc et
au moment de rentrer à la salle où on
devait échanger avec le personnel et les
motiver pour le respect des procédures
de sûreté je me rends compte que la
salle elle est pleine mais elle est pas
pleine des mers ou des des militants
invités membres de la commission locale
d'information sur le nucléaire et les
pleine des mêmes cercle avait été faite
remplie pour que l'échangeait pas lieu
en fait voilà
alors
en entendant le contenu du
de l'accord politique passé avec
Lionel Jospin vous aurez noté que ces
termes n'ont pas été intégralement
respectés
le moxa je nouvelle tranche nucléaire a
eu lieu alors que j'étais ministre
aucune communication sur les contrats de
retraitement
n'a été possible on m'a opposé le secret
des affaires
mais je n'ai pas claqué de porte je n'ai
pas menacé je n'ai pas fait de chantage
j'ai beaucoup échangé avec le PM qui
savait parfaitement que s'il avait été
amené à décider la construction d'un EPR
je serai amené à quitter son
gouvernement mais je vous ai entendu
poser à plusieurs reprises des questions
sur le sujet les choses elles ne se sont
pas passées comme vous semblez
l'imaginer il n'y a pas d'un côté
un gouvernement de gens qui bossent et
puis de l'autre côté un trublion qui
fait des menaces qui claquent la porte
etc on était dans un échange vraiment et
si le ne le juge pas aussi dans l'EPR
mais il était parfaitement libre son
choix
j'aurais dit je m'en vais et il aurait
choisi quelqu'un d'autre mais j'aurais
pas forcément faire une RAM national
parce que si j'avais voulu faire des
drames chaque fois que j'avais j'étais
en comment dirais en tension sur un
arbitrage j'aurais pu le faire toutes
les semaines et cette affaire de perdre
n'a pas été un drame majeur ou
supplémentaire lors d'une discussion
comme on avait souvent et au moment où
il s'interrogeait sur le fait de savoir
si c'était intéressant ou pas d'un côté
on avait à peu près aucun dossier
concret d'EDF et de l'autre côté je lui
dis puis si tu étais amené des signes tu
te rappelles que je je serai plus là
voilà mais c'était surtout de la plutôt
de la conversation j'ai pas j'ai pas
fait de de menaces j'ai pas dit si tu
n'es pas gentil j'arrête de respirer
pour voilà j'avais l'impression que
c'était un peu cette tonalité dans les
questions que vous aviez posées
d'une façon plus générale je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure je comprends pas
l'opposition permanente que vous semblez
faire entre la politique qui serait
suspecte et la technique qui serait en
train qui serait exemples de tout
soupçon d'abord parce que pour moi la
politique c'est pas ça c'est pas
médiocre on est élu pour ça vous êtes
élu pour ça ça veut pas dire qu'on
décide sur la base de rapport de force
ordi donc chantage ou de menaces ou
pression ou d'intrigues ça veut dire
qu'on prend en compte les éléments
techniques mais pas que on prend aussi
les opportunités les contraintes
économiques le contexte diplomatique le
contexte sociétal le contexte social
l'emploi par exemple j'y reviendrai sur
un dossier sur lequel
ma décision n'a peut-être pas été
comprise moi j'ai toujours trouvé
suspect je voulais dire une démarche qui
consisterait à dire on n'a pas le choix
les ingénieurs du secteur comme de
beaucoup de secteurs d'ailleurs ils
arrivent ils arrivent ils vous disent
madame la ministre on a décidé on va
faire ça que vous en pensez on a pris
puis ils vous disent d'ailleurs vous
êtes écolo donc on a pris en compte vous
préoccupations on utilisera des énergies
renouvelables et puis on mettra des
fleurs devant la centrale j'ai eu droit
à ça avant qu'il comprenne que j'avais
besoin de VOUS vrais arguments d'une
vraie argumentation
sur les choix énergétiques de la France
ceci étant dit donc quand on parle des
fondements du processus décisionnel vous
me demandez tout d'abord si les concepts
de souveraineté d'indépendance était
ensuite questionnement c'est un
gouvernement et au moment de la prise de
fonction donc je vous l'ai dit ça
n'était pas pour moi un questionnement
il me semblait évident que notre
souveraineté totale et notre
indépendance très limitée et je me
souviens pas de grand débat sur ces
questions
mais j'ai toujours pensé que les pistes
les plus efficaces pour restaurer
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
passé par un renforcement des
coopérations européennes et une
solidarité forte entre État membre et
c'est comme ça que ça se passe à ce
moment-là dans les négociations
internationales notamment à Kyoto
la solidité de la position européenne a
empêcher un accord faible voulu par les
États-Unis on pourrait y revenir si vous
le souhaitez
une approche plus territorialisée plus
décentralisée des outils de production
avec la production de schéma régionaux
de l'énergie et une politique
énergétique d'économie d'énergie
d'efficacité énergétique
vous me demandez ensuite quels sont les
principales décisions que j'ai été amené
à prendre en matière énergétique leur
fondement scientifique économique
politique
par exemple qui est quelqu'un que j'ai
qui était à l'époque
administrateur général du CEA qui était
pas franchement un anti-nucléaire et
avec lequel les relations auraient pu
être crispé j'ai eu d'excellente
relation avec lui parce qu'il aimait
beaucoup le débat d'idées qu'il est
cherché toujours à argumenter il a
répondu clairement à vos questions et il
dit on était dans une situation de
surproduction et on exportait beaucoup
avec des réacteurs neufs
Neil swing aussi que déjà à l'époque
aurait été détecté le problème
de Supply Chain
et qu'il aurait été signalé au caddf
auquel participer les représentants de
l'État c'est amusant quand même de se
dire ça c'est qu'effectivement on pose
pas un problème de façon frontale quand
on identifie mais on se décharge de la
toute responsabilité on en parlant dans
un endroit où on n'est pas sûr que ce
sera relayé enfin bon toujours est-il
que à cette époque là je suis plus
préoccupé
par le fait qu'adf encourage des usages
nouveaux de l'énergie de l'électricité
cherche à exporter l'électricité
excédentaire en base je pense par
exemple au projet ligne THT du son port
vers l'Espagne
que
que par la sécurisation des
approvisionnements d'électricité je
pense la question sera posée plusieurs
années plus tard voilà à l'époque on
pose pas non plus la question de la
prolongation de la durée de vie des
centrales on a une association de
surproduction importante les dernières
centrales sont mises en service en 2000
et en 2002 et donc on n'est pas du tout
en train de se dire on va manquer on est
pas du tout
quid de l'ouverture me demandez-vous la
fermeture et la maintenance de capacité
de production d'énergie dont celle du
parc alors
à ce stade il me paraît utile de redire
qu'un ministre ne prend pas de décision
de cette sorte seul dans son bureau
parce qu'elles ont un impact territorial
économique social
dans le cas de la tutelle sur les
installations classées j'ai été amené à
demander la fermeture temporaire ou plus
prolongée d'installation qui produisait
de façon marginale de l'énergie de la
chaleur ou de l'électricité des
incinérateurs d'ordures ménagères qui
étaient émetteurs de grande quantités de
dioxines des centrales vétustes au
charbon notamment je sais que ça vous
intéresse monsieur le Président n'y
reviendra si vous le souhaitez dans le
champ du nucléaire je ne l'ai pas pris
la décision de fermeture de super Phénix
mais je reconnais bien volonté l'avoir
inspiré souhaité et soutenu en revanche
j'ai demandé l'arrêt de l'atelier
technique du plutonium de Cadarache
usine de fabrication de construite sur
une faille sismique dont l'autorité de
sûreté demander la fermeture depuis 94
ça illustre bien d'ailleurs le
fonctionnement de André Claude Lacoste
quand il veut qu'on continue à faire
fonctionner les belles villes il va voir
qu'il s'empirer quand il veut qu'on
ferme les techniques du plutonium c'est
moi qui viens voir
même chose pour Phoenix je n'ai obtenu
la fermeture ni de l'un ni de l'autre
j'ai été en routine
amené à suivre de nombreux dossiers
préoccupants et à contrebalancer
l'influence de ceux qui avaient tendance
à les occulter ou les relativiser pour
ne pas handicaper la production j'ai
cité donc la porosité de l'enceinte de
la centrale de Belleville la rupture de
la digue de la centrale du Blayais et
l'inondation consécutives du sous-sol
avec la perte des pompes de
refroidissement des réacteurs qui est
l'incident le plus sérieux auquel j'ai
été confronté dans ces deux cas
retardé DF pas de quelques mois de
plusieurs années à réaliser des travaux
nécessaires prescrits par la DRIRE ou la
décine le problème dans cette affaire ça
n'est pas la ministre antinucléaire
c'est la désinvolture des DF qui menace
la sûreté
il y a eu aussi le dossier des rejets
radioactifs de la Hague en mer en
violation de nos engagements
internationaux on avait signé le traité
OSPAR et on n'aurait jamais dû relarguer
autant de radioéléments les amis dans le
circuit de refroidissement de Civaux et
j'en passe
en tant que membre du gouvernement j'ai
alerté chaque fois que c'était
nécessaire j'ai assumé aussi y compris
les conséquences de choix qui n'étaient
pas les miens j'ai travaillé au
renforcement des moyens de surveillance
de contrôle d'expertise le nez de Jospin
vous la cité avec la création de l'IRSN
par la loi du 9 mai 2001 la loi 2001 398
c'est un épique créé à partir de l'ipsm
qui dépendait jusqu'à lors du CEA et de
le prix qui était jusque là sous la
tutelle de la santé
le travail sur le projet de loi sur la
sûreté nucléaire a été largement
entravée et a été l'objet de longues
discussions
mais
on a comme franchi les premières étapes
qui ont conduit à mettre en évidence la
nécessité d'une autorité indépendante du
pouvoir politique et la deuxième partie
c'était et des exploitants avant la loi
du 13 juin 2006 sur la transparence et
la sûreté j'insiste là-dessus pourquoi
parce que ça me paraissait important
d'avoir
on pourra le détailler plus tard si vous
le voulez mais le monde du nucléaire est
un tout petit monde dans lequel
les principaux dirigeants ont fréquenté
les mêmes écoles
assume des allers-retours permanents
entre les directions centrales de Bercy
par exemple et les grandes entreprises
publiques ou privées du secteur et donc
on a on a quand même un fonctionnement
assez
[Musique]
endogènes endogamique et aujourd'hui
l'ASM est indépendant du pouvoir
politique mais elle n'est pas totalement
des exploitants sauf que c'est pas
facile de résoudre ce problème parce
qu'il faut des gens compétents et des
compétences pluralistes aussi au sein de
la SN donc je ne je n'ai pas de solution
magique pour régler ça dernier dossier
sur lequel j'étais amené à travailler
dans ce cadre
de déchets dans les accords vers PS on
insistait effectivement sur la le
respect de les trois axes et sur la
réversibilité du stockage qui se qui ont
été ensuite acquis et réaffirmé par
plusieurs lois les trois axes la
séparation transmutation du stockage
dans les couches géologiques profondes
en testant plusieurs hypothèses de sol
et la subsurface
vous me posez ensuite j'arrive au bout
vous inquiétez pas vous me posez ensuite
des questions sur la planification de la
politique énergétique je
souhaite juste vous répondre sur les
outils mis en place par la loi
d'orientation d'aménagement et
développement du territoire
qui prévoit la mise en place de schéma
de service collectif pour les transports
de personnes et de marchandises par
exemple mais aussi pour l'énergie
c'est schémas de service collectif était
un outil tout à fait intéressant pour
les collectivités qu'on souhaitait s'en
emparer mais effectivement les les
schémas régionaux de l'énergie n'ont pas
été construits partout je vous ai cité
les contrats de plan et notamment le
travail qui a été fait avec Jean-Claude
guisso sur la relance du fret
ferroviaire avec la commande de nouveaux
matériels l'identification de sillon
dédiée les projets de tunnel ferroviaire
transalpin j'aurais pu citer aussi le
renforcement des moyens de l'ADEME qui a
permis par exemple d'ouvrir des points
énergies partout
et j'en profite pour dire un mot puisque
monsieur
Merlin ex dirigeant de RTE a cru pouvoir
insinuer que j'en aurai empêché la
construction ce n'est pas le cas je
tiens à votre disposition un article de
presse qui rencontre de ma position
prise fermement dans le cadre de ce
dossier il se trouve que la ligne THC
boutreuse qui était censé sécuriser
l'approvisionnement d'électricité de la
région PACA dont Nice traversait le Parc
Naturel du Verdon
et que la Commission nationale du débat
public a permis d'aboutir
d'accoucher de deux tracés alternatifs
moins pénalisant pour l'environnement et
plus sûr pour la sécurité de
l'approvisionnement électrique menacée
par les incendies de forêt je ne sais
pour quelle raison cette ligne a
finalement pas été construite
ultérieurement mais mon ministère avait
pris fermement opposition pour la
réalisation en tout cas d'une
sécurisation
à très haute tension de
l'approvisionnement électrique de PACA
vous me demandez enfin
quels investissements ont eu lieu dans
la recherche dans les énergies
renouvelables
ça fait partie des sujets qui me
préoccupent un petit peu d'ailleurs
cette
à l'époque
[Musique]
je vais me poser la question à maintes
reprises de savoir
de quels moyens je dispose pour faire
avancer la recherche sur les
renouvelables c'est l'époque ou EDF
achète un tour de bras
dit brevets officiellement pour les
tester dans le centre de recherche des
Renardières en pratique pour les
enterrés on n'a jamais vu ressortir des
Renardières un brevet porté racheté par
EDF mais nous évidemment sur tout un tas
de sujets qui ont mûri depuis les pompes
à chaleur les éoliennes etc donc on ne
peut même plus parler combien de deux
ans vous avez vu par exemple que Siemens
viennent mettre sur le marché des pales
recyclables et d'ailleurs recyclé pour
des éoliennes c'est nouveau je pense que
dans quatre ans dans 5 ans on parlera
plus du tout des éoliennes comme on en
parle maintenant et pas non plus
d'ailleurs les produits des panneaux
solaires donc le l'essentiel des cris de
et alors d'évoluer au nucléaire
et le reste d'une façon chaque fois
qu'on est en panne sur un dossier
on met en avant le fait que cet outil
pourrait faire avancer la recherche sauf
que je constate que certains de ces
investissements sont absolument rineux
n'ont rien à voir avec le montant des
crédits de recherche attribués sur la
base des appels d'offres de l'Agence
nationale de la recherche par exemple
dans d'autres domaines on rajoute plutôt
de 2-0 là quand on est dans le nucléaire
et et que finalement on travaille au
doigt mouillé avec des dossiers mal
foutus ou pas de dossiers au moment où
si géo est décidé par exemple on se dit
pas c'est 5 milliards c'est 10 milliards
c'est 20 milliards c'est 30 milliards on
parle pas d'argent
ce qui est quand même très choquant
alors qu'il s'agit effectivement d'un
outil de recherche destiné à tester la
relation enfin je dirais le comportement
face à l'eau mouvement de la croûte
terrestre etc etc à tester la
réversibilité donc même chose pouritaire
ITER on dit au départ c'est 5 milliards
d'euros puis quatre ans plus tard c'est
10 aujourd'hui on en est à 44 c'est
arrêter depuis plusieurs années pour des
prendre de corrosion aussi moi je sais
pas si ça produira un jour quoi que ce
soit mais j'ai évité je me souviens
qu'on mette des sous sur le rubiatron
Claude Allègre et qui doit être
compétent en géologie mais qu'il était
pas forcément
en nucléaire en tout cas il était pas
plus compétent que moi ni il était
ardemment pour investisse sur un
rubiatron parce qu'il était il avait dû
croiser Carlo Ruby dans un coloc ou je
sais pas quoi donc il était fanatique et
frénétique sur le sujet voilà donc je
quand on parle de recherche on a besoin
aussi de savoir si on parle de recherche
fondamentale de recherche appliquée de
recherche en vue d'un développement à
court moyen long terme
la recherche justifie pas tout elle ne
peut pas être fondée sur des tours de
passe-passe et des audac sémantiques
sans fondement scientifique elle doit et
là j'identifier à la fois un problème de
méthode et un problème de ressources
c'est-à-dire le nucléaire n'est pas
soumis aux règles des autres secteurs de
la recherche alors que les ressources
sont comptées que les équipes leur
misère etc etc voilà
je vais de côté superhénix je terminerai
là-dessus parce que je crois que c'est
un sujet qui vous intéresse beaucoup
pour rapidement terminer sur le marché
européen l'énergie la creux est créée
par la loi du 10 décembre 2000 de
modernisation du service public de
l'énergie en application du traité de
Lisbonne et des directives du paquet
énergie négociable par question Pierret
j'imagine en tout cas moi je n'ai pas
été associée aux discussions préalables
et je n'avais d'ailleurs pas à l'être au
regard de mes compétences ministérielles
je ne pense pas que des décisions
importantes ait été prises d'emblée vous
me demandez si le Conseil des
régulateurs européens
avaient été porté à ma connaissance je
ne m'en souviens pas je pense qu'il n'a
il a dû être installé de façon théorique
par le biais d'une réunion bruxelloise
avant mon départ du gouvernement mais il
a commencé réellement ses travaux qu'un
peu plus tard voilà alors super Phénix
c'est
évidemment un dossier important
ce n'est pas parce que la super Phénix
figurait dans les accords RPS qu'il
comportait une dimension idéologique
ça a pas été un équipement merveilleux
sacrifié à mes pulsions nucléaires le PS
n'était pas antinuaire et pas davantage
nos partenaires de la gauche pluriel
évidemment vous savez pour le PC mais
vous imaginez Jean-Pierre Chevènement il
avait pas sa langue dans sa poche non
plus si cette décision s'est imposée
c'est parce que les arguments avancés
ont convaincu le Premier ministre il
vous l'a dit
je ne suis pas ingénieur je suis médecin
je parle français aussi et je fais
attention au terme utilisé dans le
domaine du nucléaire on joue avec les
mots
on ne retraite pas on sépare de
l'uranium de traitement ou plutonium des
produits de fission instables des trans
Uraniens des actinides
on vitrifie on compte ne risque on
stocke mais on ne retraite pas on ne
recycle pas bon on incidère pas non plus
les déchets radioactifs on les
transforme en les bombardant de neutrons
pour qu'un isotope devienne un autre
isotope
je vous ai entendu dire aussi qu'à une
exception près Corinne Lepage toutes les
personnes que vous avez auditionnées
jugées regrettable arrêt de super
Phoenix j'en suis pas étonné compte du
pedigree de la plupart d'entre eux mais
quand même certains à la mémoire courte
et
certains sont d'ailleurs montrés bien
plus prudents lors de l'audition je
reprends l'audition de Yannick des
Scatta
il admet que le prototype du réacteur à
neutrons rapides avait connu depuis 85
une exploitation chaotique
c'est pas tellement un terme d'ingénieur
du CEA ça de fait la mise en oeuvre de
ce projet rencontré depuis des années
des problèmes techniques incessants qui
provoquaient des arrêts dans chacun
durée plusieurs mois à l'époque la
réussite technique du projet était
fortement compromise et sa rentabilité
économique d'unement assurée ça c'est ce
que donne
c'est ce que dit le Jospin au point et
l'escata il dit des choses qui
ressemblent énormément en tout cas c'est
des thèmes extraordinaire prudents
super Phoenix représentait une énorme
extrapolation ce que j'ai tout à l'heure
passer de Phoenix à super Phénix c'était
un sacré saut il a connu beaucoup de
maladies jeunesse il a été souvent
arrêté pour réparation et s'il finit par
dire après que vous soyez revenu
plusieurs fois la charge monsieur le
rapporteur que déterminer le prototype
aurait parfaitement bien fonctionner il
se garde bien de dire au bout de combien
de temps il y a quel prix la
plaisanterie a comme durée de 13 ans de
déterminage ou détermination je sais pas
comment on dit
au moins décidé nous disposions des
Avignons C de certains des cadres
dirigeants de la filière nucléaire
conscient des difficultés liées au sous
quantitatives que représentait cet
équipement par rapport à Rhapsody 20
moit et à Phoenix 250 aux nombreux
arrêts pour panne et réparations je
tiens à votre disposition la liste des
pannes alors certaines sont importantes
et d'autres défaillances du barillet
oxydation du sodium primaire
effondrement de la toile du toit de
partielle du toit de la salle des
machines etc il y a quand même pas mal
de choses pas forcément gravissimes mais
il y a comme ça n'arrête pas ça n'arrête
pas donc on détermine
[Musique]
mais je pense aussi à l'inconnu que
représentait alors la présence de 5000
tonnes de liquide c'est une époque où je
commence à demander
je m'intéresse
à ce qui est prévu en cas d'incendie
sodium la réponse c'est rien on sait pas
faire et à ce qui est prévu pour
décharger le sodium la réponse c'est on
a le temps puisque ça a fonctionné
longtemps on a le temps de préparer on
s'interroge aussi sur le coup de ce
réacteur à la mission stratégiquement
floue on y reviendra un prototype un
rédac un réacteur de production un outil
de recherche on ne sait pas c'est
d'ailleurs d'une scène façon le fond du
problème
est-ce que c'est un instrument de
production
de recherche un surgénérateur capable de
produire plus de plutonium qu'il en
consomme ou un sous générateur
incinérant du plutonium j'ai écrit un
ouvrage à mon départ du gouvernement que
je vous offrirai bien sûr dans lequel je
décris la façon dont les choses se sont
passées les tentatives d'intimidation
les atermoiements les difficultés
techniques personne n'avait la moindre
idée de la façon dont comme je l'ai dit
démantelé au vider le sodium s'agissant
des négociations avec nos partenaires
européens membres du consortium NERSA
elles ont été menées par le ministère de
l'Économie des Finances ce qui prédomine
de cette époque c'est le soulagement de
nos partenaires européens j'ai entendu
certains de vos interlocuteurs qui
témoignent sous très sous serment évoqué
cette préoccupation du coût de l'abandon
de la filière je pense qu'il faut comme
rappeler la situation de l'époque
avant
notre arrivée au gouvernement les
Allemands ont abandonné la filière
surgénératrice calcaire a été arrêté en
91 calcaire c'était 327 MW par 1220
le problème de recherche de super Phénix
n'est pas très intéressant pour les
Allemands qui le disent l'un des membres
du directoire de la SBK donc c'était le
consortium dans lequel il y avait des
Belges générales et des Italiens je
crois donc j'ai oublié dit nous
envisageons de diminuer notre
participation voire de nous retirer de
la faire
donc les Italiens des Nails notre
position est identique à celle des
Allemands les recherches que pourrait
permettre la surgénérateur nous nous
serons d'aucune utilité et donc ça c'est
avant notre arrivée au gouvernement et
donc quand on arrive au gouvernement
selon je me souviens quand on discute
avec les partenaires européens c'est
leur soulagement c'est le soulagement
ils sont des dommagés par une fourniture
d'électricité à leur peu cher et
excédentaire alors qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui de cette filière un lobby
stiminant mais pas encombré par les
scrupules nous explique dans une BD à la
mode que je cite ça existe déjà dans le
monde en exploitation courante c'est une
technologie maîtrisée
il a sans doute raison nous savons que
quelques réacteurs à notre rapide
fonction à travers le monde dans de
grandes démocraties avancées de
transparence il y a deux équipements à
bélugars en Russie et un à tous en Chine
et que trois autres sont construction
quand tous les autres ont abandonné leur
projet au Japon aux USA au RFA vous avez
dans une question posée à Lionel josman
marquée votre étonnement quand vous
faites que leur présentation nationale
n'est pas été consultée c'est vrai
sur la fermeture mais ne l'avez pas été
non plus sur la création
et je pourrais ce serait peut-être cruel
rappeler que la légalisation de la
construction des centrales nucléaires
décidé en 74 a eu lieu en 2005 30 ans
plus tard
à ma connaissance il y a pas eu de loi
non plus pour créer ITER donc
investissement dont je vous ai rappelé
le coup pour une technologie qui n'est
fascinante que sur le papier
je voudrais pour terminer souligner que
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé à
Fessenheim la décision d'arrêt définitif
du réacteur de Malville a été accompagné
par des mesures d'aménagement du
territoire de soutien aux sous-traitant
les agents d'EDF étant que service sur
le site ou réorienter vers d'autres
sites de la même région de formation de
réindustrialisation qui ont fait l'objet
d'un volet spécifique du contrat de plan
et ta région avec la nomination d'un
préfet chargé de piloter un programme
d'appui au territoire et sous-traitant
ça ne règle pas tout notamment pas le
traumatisme que peut représenter
l'impact sur la vie quotidienne des
salariés mais c'est déjà pas mal donc
pour résumer
la décision a été fondée non pas sur un
rapport de force politique mais sur un
constat
le réacteur très peu produit a subi de
nombreuses pannes et à poser des
problèmes de sûreté
et je terminerai vraiment pour de bons
là avec un message sur le problème
politique stratégique donc je trouve
qu'il n'est jamais abordé du signement à
quoi rime alors que le traité de non
prolifération est en train vigueur en 70
de continuer à isoler à grand frais du
plutonium au regard du risque terroriste
et proliférant de le promener à travers
la France pour le transformer en MOX et
d'espérer l'utiliser dans des
surgénérateurs qui en produirait plus
qui n'en consommerait moi je pose la
question
j'insiste puisque le MOX donc non
seulement mes locks est en grande
difficulté à Marcoule mais on utilise au
maximum 30% de MOX dans les centres
actuels le moxusé est beaucoup plus
radioactif que l'oxyde d'uranium usé il
impose un long refroidissement en
piscine
il dégage beaucoup plus énergétique que
les oxydes d'uranium ainsi on ne peut en
mettre qu'un seul assemblage par
conteneur de stockage quand on peut en
mettre 4 d'oxyde d'uranium usé ça veut
dire quoi concrètement ça veut dire que
les MOX occupent quatre fois plus
d'alvéoles que les oxydes d'uranium
voilà
j'arrête là pour l'instant je vais
pendant que j'écouterai vos premières
réactions monsieur le Président mettent
de l'or dans mes papiers parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses encore que je
voudrais vous dire aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup madame la ministre pour
ce propos introductif
on a pris le temps je crois que c'était
nécessaire
mais ça vous démontre aussi qu'on essaye
de d'écouter tout le monde de faire le
travail quel que soit les présupposés
que vous puissiez avoir sur notre
commission d'enquête et sur lesquelles
vous avez ouvert vos propos
Parlement reste libre de la façon dont
il conduit ses travaux
[Musique]
du coup moi je vais essentiellement
m'intéresser à la période qui est celle
pendant laquelle vous avez
exercer vos responsabilités
je suis pas forcément de ceux qui
pensaient qu'il fallait remonter très
loin dans nos travaux d'autres
dans notre commission d'enquête on
souhaitait qu'on élargisse plus
largement la période sur laquelle on
travaille et on se penche
pas forcément ceux que vous pensez
madame la ministre
j'aurai une première question assez
assez vaste
parce que finalement on parle beaucoup
de
votre position anti-nucléaire c'est une
position politique
mais quelle est quand vous êtes ministre
en partie chargé de l'énergie la vision
que vous avez de l'évolution du mix
énergétique et les chemins pour y
parvenir je pense notamment aux enjeux
de décarbonation puisque vous étiez dans
votre décret d'attribution en charge de
la réduction des gaz à effet de serre on
les appelle comme ça à l'époque
je pense que on parlait beaucoup moins
de décarbonation on passait on parlait
de réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de façon beaucoup plus
générique
c'est pour ça que j'avais précisé le
voilà vous attributions j'essaye de
réexploiter comme comme il me semble
qu'on parlait plutôt d'énergie nouvelle
que d'énergie renouvelable à l'époque
mais oui voilà on est un tout petit peu
dans la dans la rhétorique ou autre mais
à l'époque on parle beaucoup plus
mon travail il va être essentiellement
d'obtenir qu'on objective les sujets
c'est que en 1973 on a un constat on a
plus de pétrole on a des idées certes
mais on décide de faire du nucléaire
et
l'idée que
70% du problème
c'est les fossiles
n'est pas largement partagée au moment
où j'arrive au gouvernement et d'une
façon d'ailleurs plus générale ce qui va
me frapper le plus c'est la très faible
culture sous ces sujets énergétiques
qu'on l'essentiel des membres d'un
gouvernement des membres du Parlement
des des élus en général des journalistes
et de la société c'est que on est
beaucoup sur sur des phrases un peu
magiques du genre le nucléaire ou la
bougie ou des choses comme ça et donc
faire en sorte qu'on essaie de partager
un certain nombre de connaissances et de
consolider un certain nombre de données
sur les questions énergétiques et déjà
une partie du problème
donc
faire partager aussi l'idée qu'il y aura
jamais une solution concrète unique un
problème par nature immense et complexe
et que ce qui va devoir faire ce qu'on
va devoir faire c'est effectivement
rebalayer l'ensemble des activités
humaines
et tenter d'abord de réduire le problème
quand un problème énorme et apparaît
insoluble on essaie justement de de le
fragmenter de le de le réduire et donc
l'idée qu'on doit associer à la fois un
travail sur l'efficacité énergétique au
motif que l'énergie la moins chère la
moins polluante la moins dangereuse
c'est celle qu'on n'a pas consommé
un travail sur la diversification des
sources d'énergie parce que c'est on
vient de vivre moi j'arrive au
gouvernement
pratiquement 15 ou 20 ans pendant
lesquels EDF a encourager à l'usage de
l'énergie pour tout un tas d'usages pour
lesquels l'énergie n'est pas
l'électricité n'est pas n'est pas la
panacée
expliquer par exemple
que
vous connaissez ça par coeur maintenant
je vous ai entendu parce que évidemment
on
je reviens pas en amont on est dans un
pays où le débat est jamais objectivé
avec des thèmes clairs on confond
énergie électricité
production et consommation primaire avec
consommation finale et donc des gens
conscients du fait que pour ce qui
concerne l'électricité tout
particulièrement nucléaire en
particulier il faut produire 3 kWh du
centrale pour un année une seule au
consommateur puisque la centrale
elle-même en consomme 1 le transport en
consomme 1 et puis l'arrivée il en reste
qu'un donc dire le chauffage électrique
c'est pas très efficace
c'est pas très efficace parce qu'on va
produire trois kilowatts pour en
apporter un seul consommateur et certes
c'est pas très cher en investissement
les grille-pains électriques de l'époque
mais
on encourage des habitants à isoler leur
logement en disant le chauffage
électrique ça n'est valable que si vous
êtes bien isolé sauf que ça va être
utilisé par des millions de personnes
sont scrupules pour équiper à peu de
frais des logements de location
pas cher pour l'équipement mais très
cher pour la personne qui qui vit dans
des conditions de confort très limitées
donc c'est c'est ça le contexte de
l'époque donc
comment on a fait pour travailler j'ai
entendu évidemment Corinne Lepage
regretté que la loi l'or n'est pas été
totalement appliquée comme l'affirmait
c'est partiellement exact parce que
cette loi était une loi d'orientation
donc avec beaucoup de choses assez
qui n'était pas très solidement
impliquante sur le plan législatif mais
il y avait aussi des outils tout à fait
intéressant cette loi et chaque fois que
c'était possible
utile etc on l'a mise en application on
a surtout décliné aussi la loi l'or la
loi sur l'utilisation rationnelle de
l'énergie loi sur l'air et sur
l'utilisation raciale de l'énergie dans
le premier programme national de lutte
contre le changement climatique qui a
essayé de balayer je dirais activité par
activité les grands champs de l'activité
et de et d'arrêter les mesures qui
permettaient de réduire les émissions ce
qui était intéressant aussi
c'était
le travail qui a été mené au niveau
européen et international c'est à dire
que dans le cas des négociations de
Kyoto où j'ai représenté la France à un
moment où Angela Merkel représentait
l'Allemagne
a aucun
les Pays-Bas le Danemark etc
notre notre travail au niveau
international a été un travail qui
consistait à faire prendre en compte les
responsabilités spécifiques des pays
plus développés et le fait qu'à côté des
outils économiques qui semblaient être
la condition indispensable pour que les
États-Unis rejoignent le trend et
s'engage à nos côtés les politiques et
mesures nationales étaient essentielles
et donc les politiques d'efficacité
diversification d'économie d'énergie
ont été portés par les Européens d'une
façon quand même relativement forte au
niveau international
si j'essaye de m'intéresser vraiment au
mix énergétique
le problème c'est déjà à l'époque que
70% de la consommation d'énergie relève
des énergies fossiles et finalement pas
de l'électricité
on parlait d'isolation des logements
alors prioritairement sur les logements
chauffés électriquement alors
pas forcément donc qu'en est-il des 70%
de consommation d'énergie
à base d'énergie fossiles en matière
d'action conduite par le gouvernement de
l'époque qui a positionné la question de
la lutte contre les gaz à effet de serre
dans ses objectifs
alors sur le chauffage sur l'industrie
sur le transport
très bien
à l'époque je vais je vais vous la dire
une partie importante de la population
des industriels des élus des décideurs
économiques et dans le déni ou la
relativisation et même ceux qui sont
convaincus de la réalité de la menace
climatique la voix que vous ne
perspective lointaine donc on a tendance
à l'époque à se contenter de mesures
aviser pédagogique
expérimentale ou symbolique c'est le cas
par exemple de la journée en ville sur
ma voiture ou c'est le cas de la
vignette
a posée sur les voitures pour la journée
pour la journée sans voiture en cas de
pollution de l'air
et puis la plupart des acteurs
économiques des syndicats dans
l'industrie comme dans l'agriculture ou
le tertiaire considèrent les mesures de
lutte contre le changement climatique
comme des obstacles au développement
économique comme des menaces pour
l'emploi
sans imaginer une seconde que on
pourrait avoir des gains de
compétitivité si on anticipait au moins
prenant les mesures win-win ou sans
imaginer non plus que non plus que le
changement climatique constitue en
lui-même une menace pour leur activité
donc une partie de notre travail c'est
de la pédagogie c'est de l'explication
une partie de notre travail parce que je
pas fuir la réponse frontale la question
frontale il faut que je réponde
clairement
ça fait partie de mon travail de dire
notre problème numéro un c'est le
pétrole
on viendra au charbon après
et la réponse je la construis avec
jean-cloud
d'un sommet
des ministres des transports et de
l'environnement qui a lieu j'ai oublié
où je pense que c'est dans un pays
scandinaves j'ai pas recherché on arrive
avec une proposition commune et on est
les seuls en Europe avoir un seul
document unique présenté par un musée de
transport et de l'environnement qui
propose une stratégie de bicarbonation
du secteur des transports à l'époque
sépare avec une proposition
d'électrifier l'ensemble du parc de
voitures individuelles certainement pas
pourquoi parce que c'est une époque où
l'autonomie est ridicule le poids des
batteries terribles etc etc donc
on a deux trois vous voyez qu'il écrit
au ministère de l'Environnement qui ont
été acquis par Corinne Lepage allait du
ministère de l'Environnement à l'Élysée
et retour c'est déjà tout un défi donc
on est on n'est pas du tout là dedans
par contre on est sur
l'investissement massif et le transport
collectifs la lutte contre l'étalement
urbain et le
la reconquête d'une part des transports
de marchandises par le rail voilà que
traduireons certains engagements des
contrats de plans il y a des régions
qu'on manifiquement jouer le jeu de ça
je pense pareil on va la région
Poitou-Charentes qui avaient été pas
dirigé par quelqu'un de mon corps où il
y avait énormément de choses sur les
alternatives à la route il y a des
régions qui ont rien fait voilà donc ça
c'est il y avait ça à l'époque
j'ai milité pendant 20 ans contre la
perspective d'une mise à grand gabarit
du Canada Rhône
et je me suis appuyé sur des études
fournies par l'observateur économique
des transports de Lyon
qui montrait que la réalisation du canal
aurait conduit pour l'essentiel à
prendre des parts de marché au rail et
pas à la route parce qu'on transporte
pas les mêmes marchandises
sur la route et sur la voie fluviale sur
la voie fluorée bien vous aurez des
fleurs coupées des produits laitiers etc
etc et sur la sur la voie fluviale
dépend des rues voilà et par ailleurs il
y a 25 ans certains avaient déjà
anticipé sur
la misère de l'alimentation en eau de la
Franche-Comté avec son sous-sol
karstique vous avez comme moi vu que le
doux a été sec pendant plusieurs années
consécutives l'été donc je sais pas avec
quel eau vous auriez rempli les écluses
magiques du Canada grand gabarit voilà
je suis plutôt contente de d'avoir fait
par contre le programme de
réindustrialisation appelée avenir du
territoire souverain a été interrompu
après 2002 et je trouve ça assez dommage
quoi je trouve ça assez dommage parce
que c'était un programme qui permettait
dans cette région assez industrielle et
mal connue
d'intensifier les liens avec ses voisins
en Alsace et en Bourgogne
donc on
du coup vous ouvriez la porte de la
discussion sur le charbon donc allons-y
[Musique]
je pense que vous avez j'ai recherché
parce que je voulais pas à quoi vous
allusion quand vous avez fait allusion
ma position sur le charbon
j'ai retrouvé une interview dans
Libération du 23 octobre 98 et j'ai
retrouvé une intervention que j'ai faite
le 11 juin 98 devant l'Assemblée
nationale donc c'est peut-être là-dedans
que vous avez trouvé ça en gros ma
position sur le charbon était liée au
fait que une bonne partie des pays en
voie de développement n'ont pas d'autres
énergies qu'un charbon acceptable ou
très médiocre
utiliser avec des techniques des
astrueux du point de vue environnemental
c'était des techniques à foyer ouvert
antédiluvienne etc
et il se trouve que j'étais amené à
travailler sur deux dossiers
particuliers qui m'ont convaincu qu'il
fallait peut-être
réfléchir à une situation
politiquement sensible c'est-à-dire que
le fait que dire alors vous parlez à la
Chine ou à l'Inde c'est encore possible
d'imaginer qu'ils aient les ressources
pour faire autre chose mais la
quasi-totalité est en voie de
développement non absolument pas les
moyens de faire autre chose que leur
mauvais charbon j'avais notamment fait
un déplacement au Kosovo quand Bernard
Kouchner était l'administrateur du
Kosovo pour les Nations Unies et
couchère me disait on produit un seul
kilowatt-heure par kilo de mauvaises
limites au Kosovo
et il était demandeur de solutions
techniques pour améliorer la rentabilité
évidemment dans la situation du Kosovo
qui était à la fois en faillite
financière et en guerre enfin qui
sortait d'une guerre il était hors de
question d'imaginer les investissements
coûteux de moyens termes mais voilà donc
on s'était posé la question de savoir si
les techniques déployées en France pour
mieux utiliser le charbon ne pouvait pas
être transféré rapidement au Kosovo pour
améliorer leur bilan énergétique et donc
je me suis j'ai été amené à me pencher
sur un deuxième dossier qui était celui
de la centrale de Gardanne
en disant d'abord la centrale de gardien
avait reçu un feu vert du ministère de
l'Industrie et de l'environnement 92
donc avant qu'on arrive il y avait une
centrale de 250 MW et une en project a
pas été construite de 600 et c'était une
technique alors je suis pas l'ingénieur
je regrette beaucoup mais
une centrale à l'ifudisation
dans laquelle on mélangeait du charbon
concassé avec du calcaire pour permettre
de désulsurer et la température de
travail faisait que on émettait moins
d'oxyde d'azote donc le ça nous avait
semblé intéressant de laisser
fonctionner cette centrale en se disant
c'est une solution peut-être de
transition
peu capitalistique pour des produits
pour des économies en transition voilà
je vous cache pas aussi qu'il y avait
250 emplois à la clé que c'était une
un territoire qui était déjà travaillé
au corps par des extrêmes avec
énormément de problèmes et un taux de
chômage très élevé et que l'emploi a
joué aussi dans la décision de mettre en
service la centrale qui a été fermée
depuis pour voir effectivement si
c'était intéressant du point de vue
environnemental sinon j'ai jamais
imaginé qu'on pouvait remplacer ce sera
nucléaire par les centrales à charbon
évidemment
merci beaucoup dans votre propos
introductif
vous avez évoqué dans le contexte
français de l'époque sur production
enfin de production excédentaire
la volonté d'exporter notamment
d'exporter vers l'Espagne
aujourd'hui une des visions qu'on a du
système électrique consiste à maximiser
les les interconnexions pour optimiser
l'intermittence des productions
j'ai le sentiment mais j'ai peut-être
mal compris
que ça vous dérangeait cette logique de
chercher à exporter vers l'Espagne
et je peux pas m'empêcher de mettre ça
en lien avec la présentation qui nous a
été faite à l'occasion d'une précédente
audition de la complexité et du temps
qu'il a fallu pour réaliser
l'interconnexion entre la France et
l'Espagne
je crois plus de 20 ans près de 20 ans
pour faire l'interconnexion électrique
entre entre la France et l'Espagne
est-ce que est-ce que voilà il y a eu
des volontés de ralentir cette
interconnexion à un moment donné ou pas
parce que le contexte de l'époque était
différent
alors bon j'ai été mise quatre ans c'est
déjà long mais
je n'ai pas une telle influence qu'en 4
ans j'ai pu expliquer un ralentissement
du dossier sur 20 ans je vous jure que
le retard de l'EPR a fait mon vide mais
c'est pas moi non plus mais le
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
vous avez EDF qui arrive avec un projet
et qui dit voilà
on va passer à travers la vallée du son
port et on va tracer le nez à très haute
tension etc etc pour exporter notre
électricité vers l'Espagne et moi je
déteste comme mettre le couteau sous la
gorge sans m'apporter des éléments de
choix objectif donc on pose des
questions pour que l'usage l'électricité
vient d'où donc c'est Golfech je crois
etc
et je pose la question des conditions
économiques d'autant plus que l'accord
politique sur lequel je me suis engagé
prévoit que les cons la transparence
doit être faite sur les contrats et donc
je n'ai pas de réponse là-dessus donc je
me dis c'est comme un peu fort de café
en France on supporte la construction
des centrales le démantèlement des
centrales le traitement ad vitamines des
déchets nucléaires la construction des
lignes très haute tension qui saccage
des valets pour exporter des kilowatts
excédentaires dans des conditions
économiques non précisées non précisé
parce que ce qui est intéressant le
diable il est dans les détails il est
pas dans est-ce que c'est intéressant
d'exporter l'électricité vers l'Espagne
c'est à quoi on s'engage est-ce que
est-ce qu'on s'engage avoir une quantité
garantie d'export quelque chose dont
besoin en France à quel prix etc etc moi
je je déteste enfin c'est pas moi qui
pourrait la décision je précise dans
cette affaire c'était le c'était le
ministère de l'Industrie mais on a
discuté ensemble mais c'était absolument
pas transparent à l'époque il y a aussi
je sais pas si vous en souvenez un
énorme débat sur
sur un projet routier qui est censé
traverser les Pyrénées au collusion port
vous savez on ne sait que ce qu'on nous
a dit de cette époque là avec le
rapporteur on ne sait que ce qu'on nous
a dit de cette époque là avec on se le
rapporteur
je sais pas à qui vous avez déjà posé
cette question donc à l'époque et donc
ce projet routier qui est censé
traverser le les Pyrénées au collusion
port et des populations qui militent
pour la réouverture de la ligne
ferroviaire en disant l'essentiel de ce
qui traverse les Pyrénées c'est du fret
et donc on souhaite la réouverture de la
voie ferrée et donc je le contexte il
est aussi assez délicat politiquement
c'est-à-dire que les populations qui
n'ont aucune écoute sur le projet de
réouverture de la voie ferrée qui ne
veulent pas de la route je peux vous
dire qu'ils veulent pas non plus de la
ligne à haute tension voilà c'est mais
j'ai pas eu j'ai pas été amené à prendre
de décision là-dessus j'ai posé des
questions j'ai pas eu de réponse voilà
j'ai encore une fois faut pas vous
sentir agressé d'exposition
maintenant il est il est déjà 22h et
puis je suis une vieille dame vous savez
donc enfin je pense qu'on essaie de
poser des questions
de façon posée pour comprendre une
époque à laquelle ni le rapporteur ni
moi
n'étions en mesure de nous intéresser à
la vie politique mais ce qui nous permet
de recontextualiser de comprendre
comment les décisions se prennent
peut-être aussi d'éviter certaines
erreurs dans le futur peut-être même que
certaines des certains des éléments que
vous nous direz ce soir nous permettront
d'éclairer les décideurs futurs
mais j'ai bien senti y compris dans vos
propos introductifs que vous aviez une
forme de défiance accrue quant aux
travaux de notre commission
ce que j'ai besoin de comprendre c'est
la vision que vous avez alors de ce que
peut-être notamment on essaie de parler
du mix énergétique on n'est pas allé
très loin mais du mix électrique puisque
la question du nucléaire pour vous est
préoccupante
comment voyez-vous un mix électrique
alternatif puisque vous dites vous-même
que dans votre méthode de travail dans
votre méthode d'arbitrage vous souhaitez
avoir des alternatives pas des solutions
uniques qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme
alternative que vous envisagez que vos
imaginez
au nucléaire à l'époque
alors à l'époque on n'est pas dans
l'idée d'abord
je veux pas effectivement
revenir trop longtemps en arrière mais
le mouvement écologiste dont je suis un
cadre à l'époque
identifié
enfin des fois la sortie du nucléaire
mais une sortie progressive c'est l'idée
c'est au fur et à mesure qu'il
s'entraîne arrive en fin de vie on s'est
donné les moyens de déployer les
alternatives en combinant l'efficacité
énergétique la diversification des
sourds d'énergie etc donc ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième c'est que on
a autant je pense une exigence de
transparence et d'échanges argumentés
avec
les grandes entreprises nucléaires et
avec le ministère de l'économie des
financiers de l'industrie
parce que parce qu'il nous semble que
les choix sont pas transparents
et que on est dans une sorte de fuite en
avant et que chaque investissement
justifie le prochain on est d'ailleurs
exactement à cette période en ce moment
c'est à dire que on peut plus retraité
notre uranium en Russie mais on va
prévoir de construire une usine de
retraitement en France
on a trop de déchets nucléaires stockés
à lag me reconstruire une mégap piscine
etc etc donc on est on est toujours un
peu dans la suite en avant et donc
à l'époque à l'époque je suis beaucoup
sur l'idée de si les besoins
d'électricité c'est 25% de notre
consommation en fait
alors on doit diversifier
à l'époque l'éolien comment ça se
développer au Danemark ou en Allemagne
très très peu en France et ce qu'on voit
et pas forcément très convaincant je
reconnais tout à fait c'est bruyant
c'est pas très efficace c'est les
premières éoliennes à l'époque c'est
vécu comme très expérimental donc je
suis plutôt à l'époque je réfléchis au
mix énergétique sur réduire au maximum
les besoins et réserver l'électricité
aux besoins nobles en gros l'éclairage
et les usages thermiques le
fonctionnement des moteurs dans
l'industrie
d'accord donc à l'époque la question par
exemple de du stockage ou de
l'intermittence est-ce que c'est un
sujet ou pas
je ne m'en souviens pas je pense que on
est capable déjà de critiquer le mode
l'absence de souplesse d'une nucléaire
au sens où
notre surproduction c'est
essentiellement la surproduction en base
et on est amené à cette époque je sais
pas si c'est le cas aujourd'hui encore
je connais pas bien les détails mais à
procéder au démarrage de centrales
thermiques en cas de pics de froid par
exemple ou à acheter de l'électricité
beaucoup plus cher que notre
kilowattheure exporté en base à nos
voisins que je sois les Italiens les
Allemands ou autre donc ça ça fait
partie des sujets par contre
l'intermittence des des moyens
non carbonés de production et elle est
peu posée je pense elle peut poser mais
voyez l'intermittence entre guillemets
et ça doit être resitué dans le contexte
technique de l'époque
aujourd'hui je vous parle pas du Jura
dans laquelle je vis mais dans beaucoup
de régions l'idée avoir une pompe à
chaleur
pour prévertible
[Musique]
c'est acceptable c'est acceptable en
base qui est avoir une petite flambée de
bois en complément s'il fait vraiment
froid et à l'époque on en discute pas ça
n'existe pas
les panneaux solaires on discute
essentiellement du solaire thermique
encore à l'époque c'est-à-dire que
l'idée qu'on puisse produire de l'eau
chaude par le solaire qu'on puisse
faciliter une forme d'indépendance
énergétique dans les domaines
par du solaire ça oui de temps il y a
pas la bagasse encore à l'époque dans
les doms on fait en gros c'est du fioul
voilà donc mais je pense pas que ce soit
posé comme un des axes une politique
nationale
sérieux c'est un élément de réponse sur
la question de l'interconnexion
européenne
aujourd'hui on le voit comme un système
assurantiel global
à l'époque forcément c'est pas vu de la
même façon puisque la question de
l'intermittence n'est même pas perçue
finalement
elle est peut-être abordée à certains
moments mais elle ne l'est pas pourquoi
elle ne l'est pas sous l'angle de la
politique énergétique nationale c'est
qu'on est encore à l'époque j'aurais dû
vous le dire déjà je m'en veux mais on
est encore à l'époque où le monopole des
DF exclut qu'un usager individuel puisse
produire son énergie c'est illégal c'est
illégal à l'époque il a fallu comme pas
mal de luttes pour obtenir qu'on puisse
non seulement produire un petit peu
d'électricité pour soi-même mais obtenir
qu'elle soit intégrée au réseau ça
n'existait pas à l'époque
il me semble que le petit hydraulique a
toujours est toujours resté or
la terminaison
le sujet du petit hydraulique à l'époque
c'est qu'on commence à avoir dans
certains endroits du réchauffement des
rivières la perte de biodiversité et les
fédérations de pêcheurs qui sont qui
sont remontées mon a pas de problème de
quelle est la contribution du petit
hydraulique à la
au mix énergétique français
vous allez vous venez de décrire une
logique de fuite en avant de la filière
nucléaire à l'époque où vous étiez
ministre qu'il serait contemporaine
également
est-ce que du coup les
positions que vous portez avec le parti
écologiste elles ont vocation à
prise individuellement
empêcher de façon générale de façon
globale le le cycle nucléaire
je devrais pas vous répondre c'est pas
du tout l'objet de votre commission
d'enquête j'ai compris et je vous ai dit
aussi que j'avais plus de responsabilité
nationale sur le plan politique donc je
n'ai que mon avis de citoyenne sur la
question l'idée c'est pas d'empêcher je
crois que on n'a jamais été dans un
fonctionnement antidémocratique qui
n'irait en fonctionnement correcte du
Parlement par exemple
par contre et d'ailleurs par le passé
vous pouvez citer le nombre de
situations où des écologistes ont plaidé
poussé pour qu'il y ait des débats
citoyens et des débats parlementaires
sur les sujets énergétiques par contre
comme je le mets j'ose pas vous l'a dit
moi je défends mes convictions partout
je vais je suis pas venu avec mon
drapeau dans ma poche et simplement ça
me prend pas irrationnel ça me rend pas
stupide ça me prend pas incapable
d'écouter les arguments des autres donc
simplement je me pose la question moi
aussi j'ai envie de vous renvoyer la
question c'est que d'un côté en fait la
question c'est quelle part de la
richesse nationale on entend consacrer
à notre stratégie énergétique
c'est-à-dire que si on doit personne ne
sait combien coûterait de nouveaux EPR
moi je pars remuer le couteau dans la
plaie de Flamanville là on sait pas mais
on nous dit qu'il faudrait 2 milliards
d'euros pour raccorder le père de painly
au réseau on nous dit que l'usine Médoc
je connais des difficultés que les
tonnages de MOX qui sont fabriqués ont
tellement baissé qu'on boxe pas toutes
les centrales qui sont autorisées à le
faire on nous dit qu'on pense il
construit une nouvelle usine et l'IRSN
et Orano l'ont confirmé dans le débat
EP2 Pali on nous dit qu'on a besoin d'un
atelier français de conversion d'uranium
de retraitement pour ne plus défendre
dépendre de l'usine de sévèreques qui
est désastreuses du point de vue des
pollutions et la nouvelle piscine de
refroidissement à lag et CGO et ITER
donc en fait comment on fait pour
assurer simultanément le grand carénage
la construction de nouveaux réacteurs et
des usines que je viens de citer le
démantèlement des centrales de
production et des réacteurs de recherche
déjà arrêtés la montée en puissance des
renouvelables qui sont indispensables
dans tous les scénarios pour compléter
et les investissements indispensables
sur le repas dégradés notre situation
dans le champ de l'habitat des
transports de l'agriculture du Tertre
pour réduire notre dépendance au
fossiles donc c'est tout ça qu'il faut
faire donc moi je suis un peu bête mais
comme toute bonne ménagère depuis plus
de 50 ans je me dis qu'un neuron elle
dépense qu'une fois et que si on le
dépense
en fait on va dépenser pour des mots
clés mais on a démontré quoi jusqu'à
maintenant
Brennilis c'est pas fait chose c'est pas
fait chose on a quoi 10 ans de retard
sur le sur le programme initialement
prévu
Saint-Laurent-des-Eaux toutes les je
crois je sais pas si on a 7 ou 9 du
paligraphie de gaz il n'a pas une seule
qui est des mots clés certaines soirées
depuis 30 ans elles sont pas des mots
clés donc on fait quoi madame la
ministre ça a coûté ça va coûter des
dizaines de milliards d'euros ça
surchauffe je pense qu'il faut que
il faut que vous alliez visiter le
chantier prochainement pour voir où il
en est peut-être que vous savez quoi
peut-être que Madame la Ministre
peut-être que ça vous fera
ça mettra à jour l'état du dossier tel
que vous connaissez mais je redis que ma
question de s'adresse pas à la ménagère
de plus de 50 ans mais bien à celle qui
fut ministre à la fin des années 90
et est-ce qu'à la fin des années 90
lorsque vous êtes ministre
la pensée politique qui est celle que
vous portez qui est la vôtre et il n'y a
pas de il y a pas de jugement de valeur
vous l'avez dit en venant ici dans le
votre propre introductif vous faites de
la politique comme en tant que
parlementaire je fais de la politique
est-ce que votre pensée politique vous
conduit à imaginer que des combats
prioritaires qui sont les vôtres en
temps que militantes anti-nucléaires
comme vous l'avez assumé
peuvent être ciblés sur des dispositifs
du cycle nucléaire global et qui
permettent de fragiliser ce cycle global
et d'essayer de démontrer
l'incapacité de la filière française à
boucler le cycle
mais j'ai pas besoin de faire de
l'idéologie pour ça je constate je
constate c'est que qu'aucun calendrier
n'est jamais tenu
je fais une petite insiste sur aller
visiter choses j'ai visité beaucoup de
centrales j'ai entendu moi j'en suis
retard me hurler au téléphone que il
était pas prêt d'entendre les conneries
d'une mise de l'environnement ok c'est
pas que je sois verte qui était le
problème c'était la mise l'environnement
il considérait que l'environnement n'a
rien à voir avec la politique
énergétique mais j'ai ensuite échangé
avec anne-lauvergent qui me dit j'ai mis
des webcams pour qu'on voit ce qui se
passe on voit rien la radioactivité ça
se voit pas on voit des salles vides
avec des tableaux de commande la belle
affaire on se doutait bien que ça
ressemblait à ça qu'on avait vu ça dans
les journaux mais et évidemment j'en ai
visité mais plein des des centrales et
simplement chose ça a été arrêté en 91
ça fait 30 ans
on a comme on a pris en 2007 la décision
de commencer à déconstruire on a
commencé à vidanger le circuit primaire
en 2010 a déconstruit la cuve en 2017 on
dit que ça va être fier en 2025 mais moi
on me dit aussi que ça a pris plusieurs
années de retard que ça va produire 10
000 tonnes de déchets donc 30 de haute
activité à Villelongue donc je ne suis
pas en train de dire qu'on nous dit pas
les choses comme il faut j'espère qu'on
le fait avec rigueur et sérieux etc ce
que je constate c'est que une centrale à
déconstruire c'est un travail de chien
petite année ce qui est coûteux voilà et
que je vois pas comment on fait
simultanément tout ça maintenant je
réponds à votre question quelle est ma
position sur le sur le nucléaire
j'espère
qu'à terme on pourra
et je pense qu'on doit s'en passer
mais
en prenant en compte le coût les risques
économiques sanitaires environnementaux
de prolifération de terrorisme etc etc
et je pense que c'est devenu
extraordinairement difficile
que on avait des beaucoup de marge il y
a 25 ans et le fait de n'avoir rien fait
pendant un quart de siècle pour
desserrer la contrainte rend les choses
bien plus compliquées maintenant voilà
donc
je voudrais qu'on soit j'ai bien noté
qu'il était question de changer de la
réglementation actuelle pour que les
centrales fonctionnent au-delà de 50
voire même 60 ans moi je crains qu'on
arbitre de plus en plus souvent entre la
sûreté et la production donc ça ça me
fait ça ça me préoccupe
je crains qu'on ne puisse pas financer
des investissements aussi indispensables
que les investissements énergétiques si
on continue la fuite en avant dans le
dans le nucléaire je sais pas je suis
médecin moi j'ai un débat sur comment on
finance la remise en état de l'hôpital
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour l'école
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour l'université
voilà qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour le
programme de recherche qui sont pas du
nucléaire qui sont tous dans la misère
on a comme des chercheurs qui se barrent
partout dans tous les secteurs donc
j'aimerais en tout cas qu'on ait une
politique cohérente
j'accepte la perspective
de perspectives la première c'est que
même si on avait un gouvernement composé
à 100% d'écologie on ne réagirait le
démantèlement et le traitement des
déchets et je souhaite que ça se fasse
la façon la plus rigoureuse possible et
dans le respect des connaissances
scientifiques les plus les plus pointues
voilà et la deuxième chose c'est que je
trouve qu'on est mou du genou pour ce
qui concerne le discours de vérité qui
me paraît indispensable à garder la
population c'est que ça fait des années
qu'on a peur de dire va falloir changer
quoi
et pour moi je fais le lien avec tout un
tas de sujets essentiels je fais de la
politique par exemple je trouve dommage
qu'on soit incapable de passer une
alliance avec les paysans pour des
productions d'aliments sains en disant
on a un intérêt commun à ce qu'une part
grandissante de la valeur ajoutée il y a
vos produits vous reviennent et de
dépenser autant d'argent dans du
suremballage dans du marketing et dans
dans de la vente en lot dans les grands
magasins voilà parce que parce que ça
aussi c'est une des conditions
ça relève du choix de société on passe
notre temps à faire comme si nous
concitoyens pouvaient pas changer ils
ont appris à trailer leurs déchets ils
ont appris à prendre le train pour aller
à Toulouse ou à Marseille plutôt que
l'avion ils ont appris à prendre un taux
de bague en tissu plutôt qu'un sac en
plastique qui va faire leurs courses ils
ont appris avec leur ceinture de
sécurité et pas picoler avant de prendre
la route ben ils vont apprendre qu'à
tout un tas de choses qui paraissait des
évidences qui sont plus des évidences
c'est pas punitif de dire ça c'est un
nouvel état du monde c'est un choix de
société qu'on doit faire pour dire
qu'est-ce qui est important pour nous
c'est important la culture c'est
important l'éducation c'est important la
baisse de la violence c'est important
les décisions qu'on prend en faveur des
personnes handicapées c'est
[Musique]
vous ai posé des questions sur la
période 87 2000 2001 sur la façon dont
vous avez construit vos décisions vous
me répondez sur la société telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
c'était d'empêcher le cycle nucléaire
oui oui en 97
j'ai contextualisé ma décision en vous
rappelant en ma question pardon à vous
en vous posant ma question en
l'adressant
en reprenant vos termes à la ministre de
l'époque voilà
désolé j'ai pas compris parce que comme
vous avez vous ne l'avez pas dit que
c'était pas maintenant et que je vous ai
dit attention je suis plus en
responsabilité nationale
clairement c'était pas l'objet puisqu'on
avait passé un accord politique avec le
PS
sur les points je vous ai cités donc je
me suis battu pour obtenir le respect de
la décision sur superhésique je me suis
battu pour obtenir la réduction des
radioactives à lag je me suis battu pour
obtenir
la transparence sur les contrats à lag
j'ai pas eu je me suis battu mais comme
je vous ai dit il y a trois points sur
lesquels j'ai compris que j'avais toute
ma place au gouvernement que je pouvais
me faire reconnaître et respecter
c'était la transparence la sûreté et la
radioprotection
à une époque où la question par exemple
des conditions de travail des
intermittents du nucléaire des des
personnes
sous-traitantes étaient largement posées
je vais me permettre un point de vue
je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous bénéficions
largement des questions de transparence
et de sûreté qui ont été débattues à
l'époque et je crois qu'on l'a déjà
suggéré à l'occasion d'audition de
Monsieur Jospin ce que je relève
néanmoins c'est que dans les éléments de
l'accord politique qui sont ceux obtenus
par votre partie de l'époque on va
l'appeler les Verts puisque aujourd'hui
il s'appelle plus comme ça
c'est le la fermeture de super Phénix et
le moratoire sur le MOX ce qui est pas
n'importe quelle décision dans la
logique de cycle combustibles dans la
conséquence que ça peut avoir sur la
quantité de déchets in fine produit etc
enfin c'est pas n'importe
quels éléments de la filière nucléaire
qui font partie de l'accord politique à
l'époque oui mais je peux l'assumer vous
me demandez si je voulais empêcher le
cycle et je vous dis on prend acte du
fait que les PWR sont là fonctionnent
d'accord
y compris avec des problèmes que j'ai
été amené à régler son faire des grandes
envolées dans la presse et par contre ce
qui nous semblait relever de la fuite en
avant non maîtrisée sur le plan des
coûts des déchets et de la production ça
oui on l'a je souhaitais effectivement
que ça se développe pas super Phénix
comme je vous l'ai dit j'ai cité quand
même la position de nos partenaires
européens d'une part mais aussi donc je
vous remettrai si vous la liste des
pannes voilà c'est et puis
l'interrogation liée quand même à la
rhétorique ambiante sur c’était censé
surgénérer ou sous-généré
produire du plutonium ou consommer du
plutonium faut comme reconnaître que
l'ambiguïté stratégique était majeure et
que ça a changé au fil du temps et que
ça change parfois d'un article de presse
à l'autre d'un membre du gouvernement à
l'autre donc
c'est pas des conditions pour décider
sont pas des conditions pour décider le
MOX le MOX moi je me pose vraiment des
questions c'est que pendant très
longtemps on a produit on a isolé du
prisonium à lag avec quand même il y en
a quand même 80 tonnes sur étagère à lag
80 tonnes malgré le MOX
je rappelle qu'il avait 70 tonnes il y a
20 ans sur étagère maintenant 80 et donc
non mais on isole du plutonium qui était
une matière précieuse pour les
militaires à un moment donné maintenant
il a tellement que c'est devenu presque
un déchet et et on le remélange pour
fabriquer du MOX et on se complique la
vie on se complique la vie pour les
déchets après qu'est-ce qu'on fait du
MOX irradié enfin usé on le garde
pendant des années en piscine puis on
sait pas ce qu'on va faire après moi
j'aime bien savoir ce qui va arriver
ce qui va arriver la valve du cycle
démantèlement les déchets tout ça les
déchets moi j'arrive au gouvernement on
me dit la loi Bataille mais la bataille
elle n'était pas du tout en application
donc la loi Bataille il y a trois pistes
on dépensé beaucoup d'argent sur la
séparation transmutation mais sans
beaucoup de résultats je vous invite à
regarder les les conclusions du comité
de suivi de la commission d'évaluation
c'est ne je crois c'était Commission
nationale d'évaluation
stockage dans les couches géologiques
profondes stockage en surface ou en
surface et dans les coups géologiques
profondes des censé explorer les
possibilités dans le granit dans
l'argile dans d'autres dans d'autres
hypothèses géologiques bon c'était pas
fait je l'ai fait je l'ai fait quand je
suis arrivé je l'ai fait avec Christian
Piret au sein du gouvernement on a pris
nos responsabilités donc non j'étais pas
dans l'idée de t'empêcher par contre la
fuite en avant oui ça me paraissait bien
de se poser de réfléchir
merci bien monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre pour ces premiers éléments
une question sur le contexte politique
de l'époque votre conseiller de l'époque
Bernard laponge dans une dans un
entretien en 2018
sur une question à une question qui
portait sur l'influence
des vers dans le gouvernement et sur
votre propre influence sur les décisions
du gouvernement
en particulier en matière nucléaire à
estimer que cette influence était assez
faible moins faible que sembler le dire
le Premier ministre Lionel Jospin la
semaine dernière puisqu'il l'a qualifié
de très faible voire nulle
simplement Bernard Laplanche dans cet
entretien évoque deux points qui lui
paraissent être des points sur lesquels
vous avez eu une influence décisive dans
le respect de l'accord politique c'est
la fermeture de super Phénix et puis le
Pr et il décrit pour le site
vous citant évidemment on imagine que
c'est pas forcément une conversation qui
a eu lieu mais que c'est une manière de
retracer le contexte sur la construction
d'un nouvel EPR l'idée que vous auriez
pu dire au Premier ministre de l'époque
ce que vous nous avez dit à peu près
tout à l'heure c'est que
étant opposé à la construction d'un
nouvel EPR si une telle décision est
très prise vous quitteriez le
gouvernement
est-ce que simplement vous pouvez
confirmer ce propos et ce contexte
politique
je peux je ne peux pas
au moment où la gauche redevient
majoritaire au Parlement à la suite de
la dissolution
le sujet de l'EPN est abordé que sous
l'angle de faut-il ou non construire un
repère au carnet je sais pas si vous
souvenez et donc
ce site
alors je ne me souviens pas des détails
parce que c'est pas une région ça se
passe pendant la campagne ou avant la
campagne en tout cas mais ce qui me ce
dont je me souviens très bien c'est que
c'est d'avoir une discussion sur faut-il
ou non confirmer l'hypothèse d'un ePER
au carnet et on parlait pas de le P on
parle de garder le site je crois c'était
un truc comme ça et je me souviens que
le neigeuse pas donc arbitre en disant
que s'il était amené un jour à prendre
une décision sur un éventuel EPS ça ne
pourrait pas être là je ne sais plus
pour quels arguments
dans mon souvenir on décide ensuite on
se voit à peu près une semaine sur deux
quand on discute de sujets techniques
c'est en présence de nos conseillers les
siens les biens quand on discute de
sujets plus politiques qui sont liés au
fait que je suis le chef de partie d'une
des composantes du gouvernement qu'il
dirige
ça se sentait ta tête mais donc c'est
arrivé peut-être je sais pas peut-être
une fois tous les deux mois qu'on soit
amené dans nos entretiens une semaine
sur deux à aborder des sujets sur
l'énergie ça peut être l'énergie il y a
eu tout un tas de sujets sur les rejets
de logs sur il y a eu tout un sujet et
je me souviens d'une discussion avec lui
sur le ton de la conversation elle passe
le temps de la menace ou du chantage
dans lequel effectivement
l'un des ministres présents je sais plus
si c'est de je trouve scan je pense dit
EDF
recommence à
parler de PR etc et j'ai dit je m'en
souviens j'ai dit
vous prendrez votre décision mais ce
sera sans moi voilà c'était pas sur le
temps de chantage on n'avait pas ce mode
de relation et
je crois level je sais pas quand il dit
que Def n'a pas déposé de dossier mais
ça faisait partie comme des sujets un
peu compliqués pour moi c'est-à-dire que
j'avais pas d'autorité sur EDF j'avais
pas d'autorité sur COGEMA à l'époque ça
Orano ou sur ou sur Framatome etc etc
donc ça ne pouvait se passer que dans
les discussions
de gré à gré voilà
j'avais pas d'autorité fonctionnelle et
j'avais pas leur donner
donc vous vous confirmez que vous étiez
politiquement opposé à la construction
de nouveaux EPR et que si le
gouvernement mené par Lionel Jospin
avait pris une telle décision vous
auriez démissionné et que le
gouvernement Lionel Jossin Jospin pardon
était parfaitement au courant qu'une
décision de nouveau de construction d'un
nouvel enfin d'un nouveau réacteur
aurait entraîné votre démission
ça ne devait pas beaucoup
gêné ou pénible que j'avais une
influence très faible dans ce
gouvernement
je vous remercie peut-être une question
pour revenir sur sur les Box enfin sur
la partie de chapitre nucléaire avant de
participer aux autres sujets une
question sur le MOX donc je comprends
que vous portiez peut-être pardon une
question préalable vous portiez à
l'époque la sortie du nucléaire enfin la
sortie progressive du nucléaire est-ce
que vous pouviez est-ce que vous
pourriez revenir sur l'échéance à
laquelle vous imaginiez cette sortie et
dans le siège des questions ou des
échanges que vous avez eu avec le
président quel remplacement enfin
quelles énergies de remplacement vous
imaginez au-delà en plus bien sûr de la
question de la sobriété et de
l'efficacité énergétique mais qui
n'aurait qui ne saurait remplacé la
production d'énergie tout court
on est vraiment au cœur du sujet là
c'est que je constate quand on discute
de ces sujets que la quasi-totalité de
nos interlocuteurs pense un remplaçant
pratiquement kilowatts par kilowatt
usage par usage et ma façon de raisonner
était très différente de celle-là à la
fois l'idée de
répéter 10 fois mais une politique
vigoureuse d'économie de diversification
des sources d'énergie de
décentralisation c'est-à-dire que ce
qu'on a dit tout à l'heure produire 3 kW
dans une centrale pour un cheminée un
seul au consommateur me paraissait peu
efficace notre pays on fait des choix
qui étaient des choix plus décentralisés
et puis après c'est vrai que le les
alternatives c'était
selon les usages moi j'imagine bien
les nouvelles techniques de chauffage au
bois qui ont qui sont banalisés
maintenant à l'époque elle n'était pas
mais pour produire de la chaleur dans de
l'habitat isolé ça nous paraissait plus
rentable que de tracer des lignes
électriques à travers le paysage pour
yacheminer des kWh de chauffage
électrique donc
c'était plutôt un bouquet de solutions
dont le contenu en emploi avait été pesé
dans les contrats de plan et dont le les
besoins de formation aussi avaient été
évalué parce que un des avantages
le nucléaire c'est l'énergie très
capitalistique avec peu d'emploi par
millions investi et beaucoup des
alternatives énergétiques alors
évidemment on a torpillé la filière
photovoltaïque et on importe encore
quasiment toutes nos éoliennes donc
c'est pas très juste ce que je suis en
train de dire mais notre idée c'était
aussi de privilégier des modes de
production énergétique plus riches en
emploi non délocalisables à l'époque
c'était beaucoup ça donc
moi je
l'idée n'a jamais été de remplacer
kilowattheure par kilowattheure du
nucléaire centralisé par une autre
énergie centralisée
donc ce que vous dites c'est que ce que
vous appeliez de vos vœux c'est un
changement j'allais dire pardon sans
pompe faisait mais de paradigme et que
c'était pas l'idée de remplacer une
offre énergétique par une autre c'était
simplement de remplacer l'offre
énergétique existante par un nouveau
modèle
décentralisé avec des sources de
production énergétique variées
différentes mais qui n'étaient forcément
pas
calculé au kilowatt-heure près et ou
kilowatts près à la fois en termes de
production et de puissance
nécessairement étant donné la maturité
technologique d'une part et l'État le
stade des réflexions
d'où la sagesse de position c'est
personne ne demandait qu'on arrête tout
le parc nucléaire d'un seul coup l'idée
c'était plutôt de dire on desserre
progressivement la contrainte au fur et
à mesure des progrès techniques des
efforts y compris de financement de
recherche etc qu'on va consentir pour
être prêt quand les premières centrales
arriveraient à échéance à l'époque on
pensait au bout de 40 ans on pensait pas
au bout de 50 ou 60
il y a un poids sur lequel on est
parvenu par exemple
encore une fois moi je suis pas
ingénieur du nucléaire mais ce que j'ai
compris c'est non seulement qu'on
produit beaucoup plus dans la centrale
qu'on est capable d'en apporter au
consommateur mais que
le fonctionnement de la centrale
elle-même extrêmement vorace et le choix
qui a été fait en France d'un système de
production d'électricité extrêmement
centralisée qu'un jour qui se discute
c'est on a couvert le territoire de
ligne à très haute tension
et alors je veux pas vous faire le coup
de
d'entrer longtemps à les écolos étaient
caricaturés de façon un peu ridicule
comme a ici une centrale et si un avion
tombé sur une centrale d'abord ça peut
arriver mais c'est pas ça le sujet le
sujet c'est quand même un moment donné
la vitalité des territoires
bon j'étais mise à jour du territoire
aussi donc je le portais aussi assez
fortement
justement sur la question d'avant je
suis probablement enfermé dans le
paradigme du remplacement kilowatts par
kilowatt mais ce que j'ai du mal à
comprendre c'est que vous aviez l'air de
dire desserrer la contrainte
du nucléaire en développant de nouvelles
sources de production mais j'ai
l'impression que ça sous-entend mais je
me trompe sûrement une forme
d'opposition entre le nucléaire et les
énergies renouvelables c'est à dire que
enfin les énergies telles qu'on les
appelait à l'époque mais les énergies
d'aujourd'hui
quelle était la réflexion pour la sortie
des usages
qui correspondent à de la consommation
d'énergie fossiles et pourquoi est-ce
que dans le dans la manière dont vous le
présentez ici mais c'est peut-être parce
que j'ai orienté la question sur le
nucléaire mais vous vous semblez
finalement donner la priorité à la
sortie progressive du nucléaire par de
nouvelles énergies par rapport à la
décarbonation dont vous avez très
justement parlé tout à l'heure en disant
qu'elle n'était pas au centre des
préoccupations du moins pas sous cette
dénomination là
alors
non seulement je raisonnais pas
kilowatts par kilowatt mais je prends
deux trois exemples concrets chauffage
électrique
je le trouvais des astroces plan social
je trouvais des astroces de l'efficacité
et on voit bien évidemment aussi on
choisit on va pas on va pas dire on
remplace 100% de la consommation des
radiateurs électriques des grille-pains
de l'époque par du bois mais on va
utiliser de façon combinée des
constructions passives mieux isolées qui
vont utiliser du solaire pas forcément
sous forme de photovoltaïque sur le toit
mais de d'accumulation passive de
chaleur
avec l'effetrons plus de l'eau plus de
plus du vent plus plus mais voilà les
technologies étaient pas mûres à
l'époque quand on parlait de pompe à
chaleur c'était pas super efficace
aujourd'hui vous allez consommer un
kilowatt et avoir un confort pour 3 kW
dans la maison avec les pompes à chaleur
c'était l'inverse plutôt encore à
l'époque voilà donc l'idée c'est de
plutôt de prendre le temps de faire
mûrir des technologies pour arriver
effectivement à remplacer tout le choix
électrique plus le bois plus plus les
voitures moi je fais pas partie des gens
qui pensent que la solution
s'électrifier les voitures c'est d'abord
de faire baisser leur poids et c'est
aussi développer les transports
collectifs les modes de
déplacement plus plus doux bon alors
c'est une évidence une banalité
aujourd'hui ça n'était pas il y a 25 ans
à l'époque c'était pittoresque on
proposait de faire lors de la journée
sans voiture les élus étaient tous
contents de grimper sur un vélo voilà et
ils avaient l'impression d'être des
héros et oui aujourd'hui c'est devenu
banal donc simplement
ça jamais été des politiques en vrai
grandeur porter avec la ténacité
nécessaire mais vous savez je ne dis pas
qu'on avait des solutions mais
ce que je voulais éviter à tout prix
c'était d'abord la fille en avant
c'était qu'on refasse de la politique
qu'on fasse des choix de société qu'on
se
retourne le problème plutôt que de dire
on répond à chaque demande de la société
même débile de quoi est-ce qu'on a
vraiment besoin et je suis d'ailleurs
étonné de voir que moi j'ai beau être
écolo je me pose des questions qui sont
peut-être atypiques mais par exemple
est-ce qu'on a pas besoin de relocaliser
de l'industrie primaire dans notre pays
fabriqué du vert de l'acier du bois
enfin voilà on a besoin d'avoir une
industrie du médicament on a besoin
d'avoir des aliments peu transformés
et parce que là qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
laisse notre pays produire du carbone
pour nous quoi avec leur charbon bon
donc
on me dit mais qu'est-ce que vous
proposez le premier énorme j'ai pas de
solution magique
donc je propose de le réduire je propose
de diversifier et je me dis que c'est
difficile d'exiger de se contenter de
tirer la semaine dernière
des solutions à quart de siècle après
quand on a rien fait pendant un quart de
siècle et je note que des solutions
d'une certaine façon monsieur le
rapporteur vous n'avez pas non plus quoi
dire que au plus tôt les centrales qu'on
entend construire aujourd'hui grâce à
une législation d'exception elle serait
mise en service vers 2035 2037 alors on
fait quoi en attendant la question elle
est entièrement posée est-ce qu'on est
certain pouvoir s'en sortir simplement
en prolongeant les centrales existantes
et à quelles conditions de sécurité
voilà donc
je reviens aux questions qu'on a posé
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait notre
richesse nationale qu'est-ce qui est
prioritaire pour nous
parce que c'est je vous remercie
d'ailleurs pas une ministre que je vais
rappeler que dans une commission
d'enquête le rapporteur est un
rapporteur et pas le député d'une
majorité je pense que c'est c'est une
évidence donc je ne vois pas l'illusion
à laquelle vous faites référence
sur superhénix quelques questions la
première simplement pour que vous
confirmiez vos propos vous avez dit tout
à l'heure je me suis posé la question de
ce qui se passerait en cas d'une fuite
de sodium j'ai posé la question
qu'est-ce qui est prévu on m'a répondu
rien vous confirmez
et quand on a posé la question quand on
a pris la décision d'arrêt et moi
j'étais assez préoccupé par le fait que
il y a eu énormément de tentatives alors
pas tellement de des entreprises du
secteur nucléaire qui avait acté qu'on
allait arrêter plutôt du côté des ce
qu'on appelle les députés nucléaires je
fais pas de dessin je peux faire un
dessin quand même c'est que
la culture
du nucléaire parmi les élus et les
faibles donc dans tous les partis vous
avez les quelques députés nucléaires
soit ils sont issus des des sites de
centrales soit qui sont proches par leur
métier antérieures les préoccupations du
secteur sur qui se passionne pour le
truc en général il siège de la
Commission de la production des échanges
elle doit avoir changé de nom depuis et
puis à le texte voilà et puis ils sont
chargés de près 100% des rapports
sur le sujet voilà comme il y a des
préfets nucléaires il y a des députés
nucléaires donc c'est surtout les
députés nucléaires contribuent des pieds
sur l'arrêt de super Phénix à l'époque
et donc moi j'étais assez préoccupée par
le fait qu'on ne compose des gestes qui
empêchent de revenir en arrière en gros
qu'une fois la décision prise qu'on le
fasse vraiment et il y a eu des essais
sur le style ah mais laissez-nous quand
même brûler le cœur le cœur est chargé
laissez-nous brûler que après on a
fabriqué un deuxième coeur ce serait
super qu'on puisse brûler oui mais donc
le sodium à mon donner on me dit ben non
on peut pas décharger le sodium on sait
pas le faire ça a pas été prévu on n'a
pas préparé ça a pris plusieurs années
plusieurs années avant que soit présenté
un dossier donc j'ai plus gouvernement
qui qui proposait souvent technique une
méthode pour décharger le sodium
pardon mais je faisais référence à un
autre propos que vous avez tenu tout à
l'heure qui semblait vouloir dire que
rien n'avait été prévu dans le cas du
fonctionnement de super Phénix en cas de
fuite je parle pas du démantèlement de
superhénix est-ce que vous confirmez que
vous avez posé la question du fait de
savoir s'il y avait quelque chose qui
était prévu en cas de fuite de sodium
donc un dispositif de sureté et des
mécanismes adéquats et que rien n'était
prévu
oui
j'ai même présent à l'esprit la personne
à laquelle j'ai posé la question
vous voulez nous dire qui c'est
très bien
on a fait de nombreuses auditions
malheureusement sera difficile de
retrouver simplement une autre question
sur superhénix est-ce que vous avez
plaidé puisque vous avez parlé évoqué à
plusieurs reprises le rapport entre les
décisions en matière de nucléaire et la
consultation du Parlement ou les votes
du Parlement est-ce que à l'époque vous
avez plaidé pour que le Parlement vote
ou soit consulté de manière formelle sur
le la décision d'arrêter super Phénix ou
pas
non je me souviens pas l'avoir fait
les accords verps prévoyaient une loi
sur les questions énergétique en 2005 je
crois je souviens pas que la question
est jamais été posée
ça vous paraissait pas problématique que
le Parlement soit pas consulté sur une
décision de cette nature
non dans la mesure où il avait pas été
consulté sur la création de l'équipement
qu'il n'avait pas été sur la création
des centrales
rétrospectivement je considère que c'est
un problème démocratique évidemment
merci et une dernière question sur
superhénix vous pardonnerez le la
dimension science-fiction mais
si à votre arrivée au gouvernement
si plus exactement au moment d'instruire
la question de superhénix super Phénix
n'avait pas connu d'arrêt de
fonctionnement important
est-ce que vous auriez soutenu le
principe d'une surgénération
c'est-à-dire d'un démonstrateur capable
de brûler les déchets nucléaires ou pas
on est vraiment de la science fiction je
peux pas vous dire parce que ça
fonctionnait pas donc je me suis pas
posé ce genre de question
comme je vous l'ai dit moi je suis
médecin
pas ingénieur
mais j'avais vraiment du scrupuler de
prendre de mauvaises décisions que je me
suis comme beaucoup enterrée
entouré de
l'opinion variées je vous citais par
Yannick des skata qui était franchement
produit clair ou prenez pela qui est
décidé depuis mais avec lequel j'ai eu
des discussions vraiment
j'allais dire chouette c'est pas
chouette le mot c'est féconde
intéressante je suis pas donc beaucoup
des convictions j'ai aujourd'hui ont été
consolidés par des discussions avec des
personnes
issues du lobby nucléaire et je me
souviens pas avoir jamais discuté de ça
avec eux franchement parce que
évidemment 25 ans plus tard devant une
commission d'enquête parce que c'est
difficile aussi ça fait un quart de
siècle donc voilà donc 25 ans plus tard
c'est plus compliqué mais je ne me
souviens même pas avoir été en but à un
plaidoyer pour la poursuite du
fonctionnement de l'installation
par certains des grands dirigeants du
secteur nucléaire de l'époque je pense à
l'époque ils étaient tous un peu dans la
perplexité dans le doute c'est-à-dire
que je me souviens par exemple que
plusieurs nous ont dit mais tout ce
qu'on est censé faire dans Super Phénix
on peut le faire dans Phoenix quoi qui
venait de subir d'ailleurs de subir une
bénéficier je sais pas comment il faut
dire de d'investissement relativement
important pour le moderniser
d'ailleurs Phenix a dû refonctionnait je
pense de 90 à 94 ou un truc comme ça
notamment pour explorer la piste de la
transmutation voilà donc je pense que
beaucoup d'entre eux étaient conscient
du fait que le saut de puissance entre
Phoenix et super Phénix c'est important
et que ça expliqué beaucoup des
problèmes
je vous remercie de trois dernières
questions une dernière ou une avant
dernière sur le nucléaire vous avez
parlé de d'un potentiel arbitrage dans
le futur j'imagine entre sûreté et
production lorsque vous avez exercé vos
responsabilités est-ce que vous
considérez qu'on que dans l'arbitrage
sur tes productions il a une seule fois
et tes questions on a une seule fois
privilégiée la production à la sûreté
non
vraiment pas
j'ai été confronté une fois à une
demande d'arbitrage par le PM sur
la porosité de l'enceinte de Belleville
comme je vous l'ai expliqué
je pense que j'aurais hurlé à la mort si
j'avais eu le sentiment qu'en cas
d'incident les rejets nucléaires avaient
pu être plus élevés là on était dans une
zone grise en quelque sorte
je me souviens je pense que le dossier
sur lequel j'ai eu le plus
le sentiment qu'on était fragile
vraiment
c'était la Hague quoi c'était comme
blague c'est-à-dire que
le les rejets de relance du moulinet
l'absence de transparence
et puis le secteur militaire le secteur
militaire aussi à un moment donné je
demande si on peut faire un inventaire
des déchets radioactifs catégories par
catégorie Léa les BDC sur tous les sites
pour faire à l'époque ça n'existait pas
un inventaire les déchets donc l'idée
c'était de se faire une idée des
quantités et de la nature des déchets
et là donc on présente une inventaire
centrale par centrale donc les hautes
activités à vie longue c'est pas
beaucoup en quantité mais c'est cela qui
peuvent peut-être est stockés
ultérieurement dans les cochiologiques
profondes
j'en discute d'ailleurs avec nos
homologues allemands parce que eux ils
sont soutenus cette hypothèse qui
n'était pas soutenu par les écologistes
français donc on en discute pas mal je
me rends compte que des déchets à faible
activité pour lesquelles il y a
Soulaines etc bon il y a des grosses
quantités mais surtout
à un moment donné quelqu'un me dit vous
savez les déchets catégorie B là on a un
site qui nous préoccupe énormément
sur lequel on n'a pas beaucoup de
visibilité c'est Mark cool on dit il y a
des quantités énormes déchets issus de
des militaires et on sait même pas
exactement ce qu'il y a etc
là j'ai le sentiment qu'on mettait en
péril de la sûreté mais c'était pas la
balance sur tes production jamais
je remercie une dernière question
qui forcément dépasse le mandat pendant
lequel la période pendant laquelle vous
avez exercer des responsabilités mais
qui la met en balance puisque vous avez
succédé enfin Corinne Lepage a été
ministre de l'Environnement et elle a
déclaré qu'elle était plus inquiète pour
la sûreté nucléaire aujourd'hui qu'il y
a 25 ans
est-ce que vous partagez ce constat
oui même si j'admets aussi que j'ai
beaucoup moins suivi ces dossiers ces
dernières années puisque j'étais dans le
champ de la santé et que ça m'a beaucoup
occupé surtout pendant la pandémie je
pense que l'affaire de la corrosion sous
contrainte est une affaire sérieuse
et d'autant plus sérieuse qu'elle est
pas liée à défaut de l'entretien que le
générique
et évidemment la perspective d'une d'un
fonctionnement plus long des centrales
jusqu'à 50 voir 60 ans me préoccupe
comme il préoccupe derrière l'Autorité
de sûreté
merci monsieur le Président bonsoir la
ministre écoutez j'ai trouvé votre
exposé très intéressant d'une ampleur
considérable donc je vais essayer de
poser des questions qui correspondent à
cette exposé sans faire un tunnel trop
long monsieur le Président le premier de
faire la mesure du possible j'ai essayé
de réfléchir un abonné je trouve que
c'est intéressant votre votre témoignage
aujourd'hui votre audition parce qu'en
fait vous ne vous cachez pas derrière
vos petits doigts contrairement à
beaucoup de personnalités qui disent
tout et leur contraire qui disent qu'ils
sont pour le contenu clair dans la même
phrase même paragraphe ou le même
dialogue au moins vous avez des
positions vous avez des positions
claires vous avez des positions claires
et ça permet justement de le comparer de
la même façon le fait que vous témoignez
un cardio siècle après permet de
comparer différents modèles sur une
période historique qui permet d'avoir le
recul et de comparer les résultats des
politiques menées et pas seulement des
promesses ou des intentions s'il me
remet dans la perspective que vous avez
défini au début de votre introduction
c'est-à-dire votre objectif à l'époque
n'est pas la décarbonation mais la
baisse des gaz à effet de serre si je
compare les résultats de la politique
qui a été prise par rapport par exemple
par l'Allemagne sur un développement
massif des énergies renouvelables
intermittentes et le programme
électronucléaire je me permets de vous
donner des chiffres et j'aimerais avoir
votre réaction par rapport aux ambitions
que vous avez donné le programme Messmer
que vous avez qualifié de de d'excessifs
tout à l'heure enfin qu'il y avait trop
de centrales prévues dans ce programme a
permis à la France entre 1976 et 1988 de
passer d'un mix électrique vous avez
raison sur la différence à 65% fossiles
à 10% fossiles en seulement 12 ans je
pense que cette période peut être
intéressante vu l'urgence climatique le
développement des EnR en France et en
Allemagne
se fait assez fait pour la France depuis
2008 à seulement permis de baisser de 2
à 3% la part du fossile dans le mix
électrique
de la même manière parallèlement le
programme nucléaire français a permis
par contre de multiplier par 4
l'électricité produite et sur la période
l'essentiel de la baisse des gaz à faire
sur la France
est considérable et n'a jamais été
reproduit par aucune autre économie
industrielle tant et si bien vous dites
que rien n'a été fait en Allemagne
beaucoup a été fait 500 milliards
d'euros ont été consacrés au problème au
programme d'énergie 22 sur ce 500
milliards après le mix électrique
allemand produit toujours entre 5 et 6
fois plus de CO2 français donc de CO2
pardon que le modèle français donc on a
bien deux modèles sur une période très
importante de temps qui ont des
résultats tout à fait différents vous
avez quand même le programme
d'électronucléaire français peut le
critiquer comme vous l'avez fait mais je
vais même pas revenir là-dessus parce
que ces deux points de vue différents et
ça n'a pas d'intérêt je pense mais sur
les résultats sur la baisse des CO2
d'une pour le modèle français pour
modèle allemand pour la part la quantité
phénoménale d'électricité produite on
voit bien quand même que le français a
eu les résultats que vous espériez en
arrivant au pouvoir et que le modèle
allemand n'a pas eu les résultats en
termes de baisse de gaz à effet de serre
de la même manière on pourrait aussi
évidemment comparer la pollution
atmosphérique vous avez dû à juste titre
que c'était un problème très grave et
que ça reste un problème très grave le
modèle allemand qui a été suivi ou même
le modèle danois ou le modèle espagnol
n'a pas permis de baisser la pollution
atmosphérique dans le même ordre de
grandeur que ce qui a permis le
programme Messmer sur des périodes de
temps également comparables de la même
manière vous avez parlé à juste titre
des autres problèmes des ressources et
du fait qu'il fallait que notre changer
de paradigme et consommer moins de
ressources aujourd'hui les chiffres de
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
pour 2018 on n'a pas de chiffres plus
récents pour produire un terrawatts
heure d'électricité solaire il faut 16
millions de tonnes de matériaux il faut
une tonne de matériaux pour l'énergie
nucléaire pour l'éolien il faut 8 tonnes
de matériaux en moyenne pour un
terrawater donc je vais vous demander
aussi en tant que comment vous à
l'époque vous percevez le fait qu'il est
possible de généraliser un modèle de
d'énergie renouvelable intermittente qui
nécessite autant de matériaux et comment
on peut le généraliser au monde entier
de la même manière vous avez dit vous
aviez pas d'objectif de remplacer un
kilowatt-heure par un kilowatt-heure
mais j'ai retrouvé l'interview de
libération par acquis de conscience que
j'avais déjà lu c'est ce que vous dites
sur le charbon tout à fait vrai vous
n'avez pas défendu le charbon pour les
les économies occidentales mais vous par
contre vous dites strictement qu'on peut
remplacer le nucléaire par du cycle
combiné gaz vous le dites alors ça ne
pose pas le problème de la pollution
atmosphérique mais ça pose quand même le
problème des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre c'est-à-dire que si on remplace
vous serez d'accord enfin j'aimerais
avoir votre réaction si on remplace le
nucléaire
kilowatt-heure par kilowatt-heure par du
gaz vous augmentez les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre
de la même manière je ne comprends pas à
l'époque vous avez dit que le problème
du stockage je crois que c'était une
question du Président vous voyez que le
stockage à l'époque n'était pas un
problème ni l'intermittence à l'époque
je pense quand même qu'elle a la théorie
du foisonnement c'est foisonnement qui
consiste à dire que à l'échelle
européenne ou à l'échelle continentale
ou même à l'échelle française quand il y
aura pas de vent dans un côté il y aura
du vent ailleurs alors cette théorie
fonctionne en partie mais elle ne
fonctionne pas dans les périodes de très
grand froid ou les périodes de très
grands slow comment on fait maintenant
qu'on a cette expérience que le
foisonnement ne fonctionne pas de
manière générale la question que je pose
à tous ceux qui ont défendu ce modèle et
moi je respecte ceux qui défendent un
autre modèle je respecte comme j'ai du
respect intellectuel pour l'autre modèle
la question que je pose c'est comment
faites-vous quand il n'y a quand vous
avez besoin d'électricité quand il n'y a
pas de vent la nuit et donc pas de
soleil je n'ai jamais de de réponse à
cette question et quelle est à votre
époque à l'époque de fin d'année 90
quelle est la réponse que votre que
vous-même ou que votre camp politique
apporte à cette question l'exemple
allemand l'exemple danois enfin tous les
les pays qui ont choisi cette politique
à grande échelle ne l'ont pas démontré
je voulais aussi vous demander vous avez
un moment dit que le nucléaire engager
la France sur un chemin économique et
financier risqué mais dans le même temps
à la fin dans votre
introduction pardon au début de votre
introduction vous avez dit pourtant que
la rente nucléaire avait été gâché au
gaspillier je ne sais plus donc c'est
très étrange je trouve de reconnaître
qu'il existe une rente nucléaire tout en
contestant la rentabilité de ce même
nucléaire pour moi il y a une
contradiction dans les termes vous avez
dit on ne peut pas assurer le nucléaire
oui mais vous savez on ne peut pas non
plus assurer les centrales à charbon
notamment les dommages qu'ils font la
santé donc comment vous pouvez faire le
procès comprend le procès que vous
faites que nucléaire n'est pas sur ABS
certes mais le les dommages que je pense
que vous n'allez pas contester du
charbon ou du gaz ou d'autres matières
ne sont pas non plus assurables c'est la
société qui les porte entièrement sur
son dos d'une manière je pense que vous
pourrez le reconnaître aussi bien plus
pernicieuse
de la même manière vous avez un moment
et je remets dans le contexte aussi de
la fin des années 90 dit on parle que du
nucléaire dans l'environnement vous avez
raison j'ai prévu avec Monsieur gheso un
programme d'investissement pour d'autres
usages vous parlez d'investissement
merci dans le transport collectif et
vous avez parlé du transport notamment
urbain moi je suis désolé madame mais
depuis j'ai grandi en banlieue les
problèmes du transport collectif dans
toutes les métropoles françaises c'est
aggravé depuis les années 90 le métro
parisien fait encore aujourd'hui je sais
pas si vous le promets je le prends tous
les jours on siègement catastrophique
c'est une dégradation du service donc il
n'y a pas eu d'effort fait sur 25 ans
sur le transport collectif je suis
député de la Somme vous avez été député
du et du virage parce qu'il était débute
tout seul en sénateur j'ai oublié c'est
la triste pardon
les deux bon dans le Jura je ne pense
pas que les habitants des communes
rurales du Jura et une solution de
transport une solution de transport
collectif
sur le fluvial vous avez raison vous
avez défendu vous avez fait des close le
faire routage par contre vous avez dit
aussi qui s'est passé quelque chose
désolé la situation du fer outrage
aujourd'hui c'est dégradé elle ne s'est
jamais améliorée sur les périodes même
au début des années 2000 au terme de
votre mandat c'est pas passé grand chose
ou pour pas dire pour pas dire rien du
tout et la dernière chose c'est
excusez-moi monsieur le Président sur
lequel je voudrais venir vous dites les
usages et vous dites il faut baisser la
production la consommation pardon
d'électricité alors vous citez des
utilisations débiles bon certes bon les
vidéos de chat on peut contester moi je
le suis pas je suis pas amateur bon mais
pas les vidéos les vrais c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant mais mais vous dites
aussi qu'il faut relocaliser or vous
savez quand même enfin je pense que vous
vous savez que une par considérable du
fait que le système électrique est tenu
dans les années 2000 et 2010 est lié à
la forte désindustrialisation de
l'économie française si nous avions
gardé la part de l'industrie à 20 points
de PIB le système électrique français ne
pourrait pas subvenir aux besoins de
l'économie française donc j'aimerais
savoir comment aujourd'hui même avec des
voitures plus légères vous pouvez
substituer l'usage du transport
carbonée vers l'électrique ouvert
d'autres formes de hybrides et le le
logement comme vous l'avez cité mais
aussi la relocalisation effectivement
d'accord avec vous il faut relocaliser
l'industrie primaire mais comment
faites-vous notamment que cette énergie
une fois plus intermittent que vous
allez pas fermer l'usine de déjà qu'on
aura des difficultés à rendre ces usines
rentables par rapport à nos concurrents
comment allez-vous le faire et
d'ailleurs avec l'usine vous avez dit à
plusieurs reprises ça pas été relevé je
le crois par le président Laura et le
rapporteur s'ils l'ont fait comme mon
esprit j'ai pas entendu un moment qu'on
vous on avait torpillé la filière photo
vous l'avez dit à trois reprises que la
filière photovoltaïque a été torpille
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous voulez
dire par là parce que elle a été torpill
bon peut-être par l'Union européenne
mais enfin je vois pas de quelle filière
vous voulez parler en fait parce que
c'est pas passé grand chose pareil pour
l'éolien je vois pas en quoi elle a été
torpillée on a dépensé beaucoup d'argent
dans l'éolien on n'a pas fait de filière
française alors on aurait pu interroger
Madame Royal là-dessus on a pas eu le
temps malheureusement au tout à l'heure
mais c'est pas de la faute de Président
c'est de la faute de bref on va venir
là-dessus donc donc voilà et la dernière
chose c'est que vous dites et
franchement ça m'a
ben je suis désolé mais bon ça dure
moins longtemps que vous
et et
pardon je vais y arriver oui sur la
formation vous avez donné sur Super
Phénix moi ça m'étonne madame voilée
parce que les les recherches sur les
solutions pour les incendies au sodium
sont développés de manière très
pertinente par le CA depuis les années
70 c'était totalement opérationnel dans
les années 90 le côté il vous enverrai
le document si ça vous intéresse et et
donc je comprends pas cette argument et
par ailleurs si ça n'avait pas
fonctionné il y avait une option au
plomb donc on aurait pu faire la suite
génération au plomb et ce sera ma
dernière remarque là où je pense que le
Président vous a posé une question qui
était quand même très intéressante c'est
que quel est vous la solution pour les
déchets nucléaires et façon ils sont là
vous avez le nucléaire militaire il est
là les déchets nucléaires ils sont là
même vous êtes vous êtes pas radiologue
non vous êtes anesthésiste
bon bah la radiologie on a besoin de
matières fissibles donc il faudra à
l'échelle de l'humanité ça fait quand
même beaucoup de déchets nucléaire donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait c'est à dire que si
on fait pas de surgénération si on fait
pas de transmutation si on fait pas
d'enfouissement et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
donc c'est quand même la question un peu
sans réponse que que laisse quand même
je crois le parti les écologistes de
gauche je vous remercie madame
bon ça fait ça fait beaucoup je vais
essayer de faire synthétique
ça je sens
comment
profitez pas du fait que les sorties
vous savez
bon
sur les énergies renouvelables
moi je sais pas si un échec des
renouvelable parce qu'on n'a pas fait la
vérité c'est qu'on n'a pas fait on n'a
pas dépensé des sommes considérables on
a dépensé un peu d'argent par rapport à
ce qu'on avait pensé sur le nucléaire
c'est rien du tout
comment savoir ce que ça aurait donné si
on avait déployé à partir de 73 des
énergies renouvelables alternatives
intermittente plus ou moins
en supprimant le prix unique du
kilowatt-heure qui a contribué à
discréditer toute solution alternative
de production pendant des années ça
rendait Nord rentable tout alternative
et puis je vous ai parlé du rachat des
brevets par EDF moi ce que je constate
c'est qu'on a rien fait pour 25 ans donc
vous venez me dire sur toute notre
secteurs les transports publics le faire
routage etc vous avez pas fait grand
chose moi j'ai fait énormément au sens
où mon ministère ne finançait pas
directement la SNCF et les trains ne
financez pas
les transports publics et les grandes
collectivités par contre avec
Jean-Claude guessaud dans les contrats
de plans on a inscrit tout un équipement
et d'aménagement qui ont pas été suivi
des faits par la suite moi je vous
rappelle qu'en 2002 il y a eu une
alternance et je ne porte pas la
responsabilité de ce qui a été fait
après par contre ce que je vois c'est
que on est toujours caricaturaux par
rapport aux Allemands moi je n'ai jamais
oublié qu'en Allemagne on part de bien
plus loin qu'en France avec
effectivement un usage majoritaire du
charbon et du gaz russe et qui a eu la
réunification allemande avec quand même
un système de production
extrêmement arriérées qui a dû être
totalement modernisée qui a aussi freiné
les efforts allemands bon comment
tout n'a pas été fermé tout n'a pas tout
n'a pas été fermé mais voilà mais par
contre j'ai lu comme vous avez dû le
faire
un article qui est paru dans le monde il
y a trois jours
qui montre que pour la première fois les
énergies renouvelables arrivent en tête
des sources de production électrique de
l'Union européenne
22,28% du mix énergétique européen
ces sources dépassent pour la première
fois le nucléaire qui produit 21,92% et
le gaz
19,91%, le charbon 15.99 l'hydraulique
10,12 donc ça n'est pas une officine et
que le cas produit ces chiffres mais
évidemment certains pays ont dû faire
des efforts plus considérables que
d'autres comme l'Allemagne et
l'important encore 60% de son gaz
l'année dernière enfin avant la guerre
en Ukraine
sauf que évidemment vous venez de dire
un truc amusant tout à l'heure enfin
amusant non c'est de la rhétorique aussi
on fait tous de la politique mais quand
vous dites
vous parlez du mix énergétique mais vous
rappelez que le mix énergétique c'est le
mix électrique excusez-moi c'est une
petite partie des consommations le
problème allemand numéro 1 c'est le
problème de ces énergies fossiles sur
les routes de son secteur de transport
la lignée c'est pas le transport mais là
le les grosses émissions de l'Allemagne
c'est pas la limite c'est le transport
c'est le secteur des transports bon
alors on va savoir pas d'accord mais ça
n'empêche que je vous invite à lire cet
article qui montre que les renouvelables
c'est pas un truc marginal c'est pas un
truc hein
je sais pas je suis parvenu en arrière
sur ça et je suis pas parti avec l'idée
de comparer de l'Allemagne mais ce que
je constate aujourd'hui c'est que tous
les pays européens respectent leurs
engagements de monter en puissance des
renouvelables sauf la France voilà après
j'ai certainement pas proposé de
remplacer le nucléaire par du cycle en
vidéo gaz j'ai dit le nucléaire par tout
un bouquet de solution donc ça c'est que
dans ça mais je vois de quoi il est
question j'ai pas envie de polémiquer il
y a un article d'au moins quatre pages
donc dans l'article je cite un certain
nombre de solutions donc il y a quelques
jours m'accusait d'avoir encouragé le
charbon maintenant c'est le cycle
combiné au gaz je cite tout un tas
d'alternatives qu'il devait utiliser en
bouquet pour ce qu'elle s'affaire de
mieux sur la rampe nucléaire je j'ai dû
être maladroite tout à l'heure ce que je
voulais dire simplement c'était que on
avait choisi d'encourager des usages non
prioritaires de l'énergie d'une part et
de vendre du nucléaire du kilowatt-heure
nucléaire à un prix très bas sans en
profiter pour constituer des réserves
permettant de financer vraiment les
déchets des mentalement et la suite
voilà et la suite dans une entreprise
quand on fait fonctionner des
équipements on se dit on prévoit ce
qu'il faudra pour réinvestir après et
nous on n'a pas vraiment fait voilà donc
ce que je constate dans ce qu'on a on a
vendu à un prix politique
artificiellement bas donc le Water
nucléaire sur les transports publics de
fer routage etc oui je veux bien je fais
comme vous le constatez qu'on n'a rien
fait depuis 20 ans mais les conditions
étaient réunies Corinne levage avait
raison de dire que ça doit comporter
beaucoup de choses le problème national
de lutte contre le changement climatique
comportait beaucoup de choses la loi
d'aménagement du territoire aussi etc
etc je suis bien désolé qu'on n'est pas
poursuivi ces efforts comment je fais
pour relocaliser
et comment je fais pour traiter les
déchets bonjour envie de vous dire
c'est amusant de demander à ceux qui
proposaient
de pas les produire
ce qu'ils ont feraient alors je réponds
parce que s'il y avait un gouvernement
avec uniquement des écolos il faudrait
bien qu'ils se confrontent à ce problème
je pense que on a des quantités énormes
déchets nucléaires à traiter
que l'entreposage en sub surface il
repense mais en sub surface est une
solution
non seulement acceptable mais que c'est
celle qui permet le plus la
réversibilité si on trouve des
techniques qui permettraient ensuite de
séparer retraités etc plus efficacement
je constate que Orano vend des
conteneurs aux États-Unis pour ce
stockage en sub surface qui ne propose
pas en France ce qui me paraît dommage
et je crois vraiment que la solution du
MOOC c'est une mauvaise solution en ce
qui s'applique plutôt le traitement des
déchets j'ai évoqué à faire des du
refroidissement en piscine tout à
l'heure mais je crois comprendre qu'il
n'est pas prévu de recycler ou de
retraités les combustibles MOX usagés
ils comporte beaucoup de plutonium c'est
comme si cils dès qu'on a trois kilos
c'est donc on conteneurisation c'est
assez cher et assez compliqué on le fait
voyage à travers la France de lag à
Marcoule de Marcoule au centrale au
Japon etc etc ça me paraît un petit peu
compliqué
et par ailleurs le temps de
refroidissement
comme de l'ordre de trois siècles je
crois donc je me dis on va faire quoi
ça mène où ça mène si on regarde en
arrière c'est même à Louis XVI quoi
est-ce qu'on est sûr de la stabilité de
nos sociétés humaines
comment
si on a envie de rigoler aussi
et puis le torpillage la filière foot de
voltaïque je fais allusion fait que
la filière en difficulté n'a pas été
soutenue il y a des industries
l'industrie navale ou autre elles ont
été soutenues financièrement par la
France et là on a on a renoncé à
soutenir cette filière et accepter que
tous nos panneaux photovoltaïques se
produisent en Chine
sur les masses de déchets aussi je
voulais vous dire
on parle toujours des centrales mais
vous êtes intéressé à ITER dans votre
commission non parce que ITER par
exemple j'ai trouvé mon c'est un
consortium international à tous les sous
sont pas des pensées par la France mais
je crois qu'il y a la moitié qui est
payé par l'Union européenne il y a un
peu de la Chine etc etc mais on est
quand même
la fusion c'est aléatoire et puis on
nous dit on nous dit cocorico on est on
a réussi à
provoquer une relation de fusion sur une
ou deux molécules en
ne consomment pas plus d'énergie que ce
qu'on a produit voilà sauf que ça c'est
une molécule dans un micro machin et
pour ITER par exemple
on intègre jamais le coût de
construction de cet équipement 440 000
tonnes de béton et d'acier ITER 440
mille tonnes donc faudra aussi les
intégrer au bilan énergétique du monstre
quand même et puis avec une perspective
de produire de première peut-être de
provinces de fusion autour de 2070 super
quoi où est-ce qu'on en sera en 2070 moi
je suis pas sûr qu'on n'aurait pas des
des problèmes de recherche plus
urgentes que celui-là c'est un truc
pharaonique délirant avec une
consommation de ressources rares énormes
il y a plusieurs métaux rares qui sont
on consomme je crois dans ITER le quart
des ressources planétaires c'est ça j'ai
oublié les noms nos briom je crois mais
je suis pas sûr
ouais mais bon
je suis un peu inquiète
elle est pas là
qu'on attend de son retour
non
du coup j'en profite peut-être pour
aborder un sujet que nous avons abordé
dans d'autres auditions mais pas encore
ce soir
qui concernait la
[Musique]
préparation de la directive européenne
relative à la promotion de l'électricité
produite à partir de sources d'énergie
renouvelables sur le marché intérieur de
l'électricité
je sais même pas de quoi il parle de
quoi ça parle c'était en quelle année
la directive sort en 2001 donc
juillet 2001 j'ai été très très investi
dans la présidence française de l'Union
et je pense que ça a été plutôt discuté
au sein du Conseil
énergique s'il y avait un conseil
énergique
pas dans le conseil environnement sûr
et dans les dans les délégations que
vous avez pu avoir au niveau
des discussions européennes est-ce qu'un
moment ou un autre vous avez eu à
défendre les intérêts français la
question du nucléaire et de quelle façon
est-ce que vous avez abordé cela
j'aurais été frustré que ce soit pas
abordé
oui c'est bien je savais même préparé un
truc voilà oui alors j'ai été amené à
défendre beaucoup beaucoup de
les positions de la France dans de
multiples sommets internationaux puisque
pendant ma participation au gouvernement
on a donc eu la présidence française de
l'Union les négociations du protocole de
Kyoto mais aussi le Protocole de
Carthagène sur
sur la biodiversité etc etc donc il y a
vraiment été important de mon travail et
donc évidemment vous m'en parlez parce
que j'ai été mise de en cause de façon
extrêmement agressive à partir d'un
extrait tronqué d'un documentaire d'Arté
consacré aux négociations
internationales sur le climat et donc le
film une énergie qui dérange a été
produite par une association qui
s'appelle documentaire et vérité vous
entendez les guillemets parce que je
trouve que elle le mérite qui est une
association pro-nucléaire et
anti-éolienne il comporte donc un
extrait tronqué d'un documentaire
produit par Daniel Leconte pour Arte
et de ne pas penser que j'aurais trahi
mon pays et saboter la filière nucléaire
position qui a été reprise ensuite par
des journalistes à la déontologie
incertaine mais je peux être plus
grossière si c'est nécessaire par des
sites d'extrême droite par des
responsables politiques imprudents et
qui n'ont pas pris le temps de vérifier
je précise qu'il ne s'agit pas ici
d'opinion argumentée dans le cadre d'un
débat politique mais de fait alternatif
monter pour tromper ce que dit
d'ailleurs le producteur du film qui dit
c'est un montage mensonger et des
phrases tronquées
je passe sur les commentaires injurieux
qui semblent devenus une routine sur
certains sites et réseaux sociaux moi
sur les menaces de mort que cela m'a
valu
ça me faire beaucoup d'honneur et me
prêter beaucoup de pouvoir que
d'imaginer que j'aurais pu seul contre
tout l'appareil d'État de grandes
entreprises et des intérêts puissants
prendre une décision susceptible de
miner une filière stratégique et c'est
prendre tous ceux qui nous ont succédé
pour des imbéciles impuissants que
d'imaginer qu'il n'aurait pu au cours
des 20 années qui ont suivi remédier à
cette décision si elle s'était révélée
si désastreuse or personne n'y a
ultérieurement trouvé à redire pourquoi
parce que la réunion bruxellesoise à
laquelle il est fait allusion ne
concernait ni les choix énergétiques de
l'Union ni la taxonomie des énergies
contrairement à ce que dit
l'une des journalistes cité plus haut ni
leur financement
mais la seule liste des technologies qui
pourraient être utilisées dans le cadre
du mécanisme de développement propre on
aurait pu le comprendre si la phrase qui
permet de savoir ce dont il est question
n'avait pas en effet coupé au montage
qu'est-ce que c'est le mécanisme de
développement propre c'est l'un des
trois mécanismes Kyoto et le seul dédié
aux pays en voie de développement il
prévoyait que les pays riches roses
émetteurs de carbone pourrait
comptabiliser au titre de leur propre
efforts les réductions d'émissions qu'il
financerait dans les pays du Sud l'idée
qu'on puisse financer du nucléaire dans
des pays pauvres parfois instable ne
disposant ni des outils et services
permettant d'assurer la sécurité des
installations ni d'un réseau de
distribution d'une électricité
centralisée ni des ressources permettant
d'assurer la balle du cycle sans oublier
le risque de prolifération s'agissant
d’état à la stabilité incertaine était
particulièrement saugrenue
il est probable qu'aucun responsable
d'une entreprise du secteur nucléaire et
jamais envisagé de vendre ou de financer
une centrale aussi raleonée ou en
Afghanistan
l'insistance a inscrit le nucléaire dans
la liste relevé davantage d'une sorte de
diplomatie d'influence où il s'agit
d'utiliser tous les canaux pour avancer
ses pions de ne jamais céder sur rien y
compris sur le symbolique ou
l'accessoire j'ai raconté cette anecdote
à Arte pour illustrer les contraintes
d'une négociation multilatérale dans
laquelle lieu était moteur et la
considérable en perdue de son leadership
depuis et dans laquelle j'étais
comptable pendant la présidence de
l'Union de sa cohésion faire le lien
comme l'ont fait quelques populistes
avec la situation énergétique générée
par l'indisponibilité du parc nucléaire
et la guerre en Ukraine et grossier
d'abord parce que si la décision prise
avait été jugée contraire aux intérêts
de la France et leur était dénoncé de
suite ensuite parce que bien d'autres
gouvernement se sont succédés avec des
ministres en charge de l'énergie
puissant qui aurait évidemment pu rep
poser la question voilà
comme quoi cette opportun de laisser le
temps merci
bon je
en fait j'ai plus rien à boire l'eau
depuis tout à l'heure et comme on cause
je voulais pas vous faire attendre je
ne savais pas j'avais laissé mes
affaires donc
[Musique]
très bien je regarderai ça en
retransmission mais je n'en doute pas vu
les deux heures et demie qu'on a passé
avant
j'avais une question
puisque il y a beaucoup de sujets qui
ont déjà été abordés
sur vous avez évoqué les députés
nucléaires vous avez évoqué le les
lobbys du nucléaire et l'absence de
débat ou de transparence dans les débats
avec les éléments et même vous en tant
que ministre vous n'aviez pas tous les
éléments qui vous étaient transmis je
dois dire moi ça fait pas très longtemps
que
je suis député que je participais à
cette commission d'enquête et je trouve
la violence du lobby pronucléaire
absolument éloquente j'ai même reçu des
courriers anonymes intitulés juju la
et je me demande si cette
violence là ce lobby nucléaire que j'ai
interrogé à travers différents
auditionnés je m'excuse pour les propos
c'est simplement le courrier anonyme qui
est que j'ai reçu est-ce que vous en
avez aussi
eu de ce type de menace du lobby du
nucléaire pendant que vous étiez
ministre
c'était une des premières questions je
sais pas j'en ai deux trois mais si vous
voulez que je les pose à la suite ou
j'avais vous avez évoqué aussi la
difficulté
de réalisation des préconisations
gouvernementales sur en question de
sûreté notamment
def
sur des recommandations et qui mettaient
en cause la sûreté il me semble mais
vous pourrez me dire que c'est sous le
mandat de Lionel Jospin que l'ASN a été
créée est-ce que il y avait des éléments
particuliers qui ont conduit à la
création de l'ASN à ce moment-là est-ce
que c'était pour remettre plus de
transparence est-ce que c'était pour
sécuriser aussi l'action et la
responsabilité du gouvernement puisqu'il
n'avait pas forcément complètement le
contrôle d'EDF et le contrôle de ce qui
se passait exactement dans les centrales
et puis
il y avait le directeur de la SN en tout
cas nous nous a toujours dit qu'il avait
peur de se trouver dans la situation de
devoir choisir entre la sécurité
d'approvisionnement électrique de la
France et la sécurité des installations
produisant
l'électricité c'est une des craintes
qu'il a évoqué et qui nous a rappelé
lors de son audition il a également
évoqué et vous avez fait référence aussi
à la situation de la Hague et de la
problématique des déchets qui n'a pas
été traité
ensuite j'ai quand même une question
vous avez monsieur le rapporteur je
crois à poser une question sur
le pèlerin centrale nucléaire du pèlerin
et du carnet comme c'est de départements
d'où je viens
nous avons mené je n'y étais pas encore
installé mais je dis nous puisque
c'était toutes les forces de gauche et
écologiste mener lut d'abord contre
l'installation de la centrale nucléaire
au pèlerin qui a été finie par être
abrogée par Pierre Moreau en 83 celle du
carnet a reçu aussi une forte opposition
et là on a vu EDF a freiné au bout d'un
moment le projet puisque il y a le
contre choc pétrolier en 86 rendant
moins rentable l'électricité produite au
moins compétitive et en 96 il y a une
enquête publique avec 327 avis
défavorables et 7 favorables et pour
autant monsieur Juppé autorise les
travaux
finalement le tribunal administratif
juge les mesures compensatoire puisque
en Loire-Atlantique on est souvent en
zone humide et voyez aucune référence
avec d'autres projets d'aménagement sur
le territoire et au final c'est le 17
septembre 97 que le premier ministre
renonce à ce projet donc vous étiez bien
là à ce moment là donc c'était une
décision mais ça faisait je voulais
simplement me rappeler puisque ça a été
évoqué lors de différentes auditions si
vous en avez un souvenir ou pas
merci pour ces questions
si on n'a pas envie d'être traduit en
justice par quelqu'un qui s'estime
diffamé on fait attention à ce qu'on dit
sur le poids du lobby nucléaire ces
méthodes ces relais
il y a des choses qui se comprennent
c'est des sujets extraordinaires
techniques et compliqués
les ingénieurs du secteur
issurent général du corps des mines
sont amenés au cours de leur carrière
occuper des poses responsabilités au
ministère de l'économie des financiers
de l'Industrie et
occuper des poses des responsabilités
avec grandes entreprises publiques ou
privées du secteur je te dis tout à
l'heure
c'est inévitable il faut beaucoup de
déontologie beaucoup de rigueur
personnelle pour ne pas mélanger les
gens
je pense que sur ce terrain là on est
plutôt en train d'avancer de chercher à
éviter les conflits d'intérêts etc ce
n'est pas à cela que vous faisiez
allusion j'imagine
moi je pense que le lobby nucléaire
c'est pas homogène vous avez auditionné
des hauts responsables de filière qui
ont eu des responsabilités d'organiser
la production
et que parfois perdu de vue un peu les
autres dimensions sociétales de leur
travail
le dialogue à une époque d'ailleurs
rouler le lien entre le nucléaire
militaire et nucléaire civil était
extrêmement étroit et où il y avait pas
une culture de la transparence du débat
public une sorte du secret quand même
moi je sais que ministre j'ai demandé à
visiter l'usine de Valduc on m'a dit
circuler il y a rien à voir
j'habite à 60 km de là
j'ai toujours pas visité l'usine de
Valduc pourtant j'ai visité le
porte-avion Charles de Gaulle je suis
pas allé faire une conférence de presse
pour dire ce que j'avais vu après qui
aurait pu menacer la sécurité de la
France quand on est ministre on a un peu
responsable aussi quand même
je pense pas que ce soit des gens du
lobby nucléaire
qui vous insulte
qui fasse des menaces de mort moi ce que
j'ai vu quand il y a eu ces espèces de
on vient d'en parler enfin vous étiez
allé voter la polémique sur le mécanisme
de développement propre là le montage
sur internet il y a des commentaires
mais grossièrement insultant c'est que
si ce violent menaçant
faut rétablir la peine de mort pour
cette ordures nous savons et la
enfin bon j'habite dans une toute petite
ville c'est facile de trouver mon
adresse donc c'est vrai que c'est assez
préoccupant je pense que le lobby
nucléaire le vrai lobby nucléaire a
d'autres moyens de faire moi j'ai connu
chez l'évitement il vous parle juste pas
d'un problème
la recherche d'autres alliances aller
voir un ministre plus perméable à leur
préoccupations ou aller sauver
directement chez le Premier ministre
pour dire j'ai un problème et c'est vrai
que c'est agaçant quand vous êtes en
charge d'apprendre que ça a été réglé à
notre niveau dans votre dos bon
les députés nucléaires auxquels j'ai
fallu Jean tout à l'heure
sont pas tous des gens dont les
convictions sont
soumises aux puissances de l'argent et
et
la corruption il y a quelques-uns c'est
vrai quand on se dit
j'ai deux exemples au moins de députés
je cite un ministre tout à l'heure
échec électoral et dans la foulée il
crée leur boîte de com
je l'ai cité non
j'ai pas parlé de ça il y a un ministre
de l'Industrie
il perd les élections il crée sa boîte
de com et il travaille avec EDF et
COGEMA la promotion de l'EPR en dehors
de la France
il dit déontologiquement j'ai fait
attention je n'ai jamais pour le
père en France mais en dehors de la
France d'accord mais est-ce que c'est
est-ce que revenu aux affaires il est
totalement indépendant de ces liens
d'affaires justement non bien sûr que
non
j'ai présent aussi à l'esprit d'autres
alors de l'OPEX ils partent en mission
aux Etats-Unis visiter les sites de
stockage nucléaire du Nevada c'est
intéressant de voir des des galeries
avec des colis moi j'ai assisté à des
réunions du comité à l'énergie atomique
on nous présentait de façon très
solennelle des diapositives sur lesquels
vous voyez un parallélépipède moi
pratique une valise pas de poignée etc
mais c'était ça le travail qui était
fait pour contrer le plutonium c'était
fait pour pouvoir en
contrer trois kilos quoi parce qu'après
au delà c'est difficile donc je donc ils
sont partis quand même au 15 jours aux
États-Unis pour visiter le Nevada mais
avec une escale à New York etc etc enfin
ils ont rachis Kago enfin ils sont bien
promenés quand même bon ça c'est le
lobby
sur la sûreté
sur la sûreté de DF et la création de la
SN
l'Autorité de sûreté n'a pas été créée
sous je sais pas le débat a commencé à
ce moment-là et il a commencé avec deux
options très différentes il y avait d'un
côté
ce qui voulait à tout prix que la
décision soit plus dépendante du
gouvernement
les grandes entreprises auraient voulu
prendre des décisions avec l'Autorité de
sûreté sans subir les sillons
gouvernementales après son
gouvernementale notamment la pression du
ministre de l'Environnement qui leur
demandait des comptes et puis il y avait
ceux dont j'étais qui étaient plutôt
soucieux de garder des moyens au sein de
l'État
mais de couper le cordon ombilical avec
des entreprises
et en fait on s'est pas mis d'accord sur
le on s'est pas mis d'accord on avait
une aspiration à créer une autorité de
sûreté qui unifie les différents sujets
les Sud radioprotection de sûreté de
transparence sont pas des différents par
nature c'est des sujets de répondre de
la société avec le plus haut niveau
d'exigence et il a fallu plusieurs
années avant que ça se mette en place et
je pense que le compromis auquel on est
abouti n'est pas un mauvais compromis je
compte beaucoup souligne quand même les
progrès qui ont été faits en matière de
l'Autorité de sûreté
on a évoqué tout à l'heure je sais pas
si vous étiez là la question est
effectivement des arbitrages entre
sûreté et production
je comprends qu'ils aient peur mais
oui c'est ça fait partie des sujets
préoccupants pour la période qui vient
forcément
le pèlerin le carnet dit aussi de mots
tout à l'heure je sais pas si vous étiez
là
je me souviens donc j'ai répondu au
rapporteur qui me posait la question que
je n'avais jamais été amené à exercer du
chantage sur le délogepin à propos de la
nouvelle EPR mais que j'avais été
associé à la décision de libérer entre
guillemets le site du Carnet de la
menace d'un EPR alors tout au début du
mandat voilà ça figurait pas dans les
accords RPS mais la question s'est posée
assez vite
juste vous m'avez pas complément répondu
sur est-ce que il y a le lobby des
grandes entreprises
de la filière du nucléaire qui
effectivement a différents moyens que
vous avez décrit mais sur cette pas
exister à ce niveau là de toute manière
en 98 mais sur j'ai l'impression
aujourd'hui que un débat un réel débat
factuel ou en tout cas on oppose des
vrais arguments techniques sur le
nucléaire en France et aussi obérée par
une certaine véhémence violence du lobby
en tout cas sur le web mais aussi par
des courriers physiques et donc on a
l'impression en tout cas moi je on n'est
pas qu'il y a une certaine violence et
donc qui Aubert ou qui vise en tout cas
à faire taire quoi que ce soit comme
opinion à vie raison
sur le nucléaire et donc c'est aussi ça
la question c'est à dire il y a un
système de pantouflage qu'on connaît
bien je pense que les députés nucléaires
on en est pas complètement sorti on
vient de nommer Maud Brejon rapporteur
de projet de loi sur le nucléaire qui ça
a été vu avec le déontologue mais qui a
travaillé dans la filière du nucléaire
donc on voit bien qu'on n'est pas
complètement sorti de ce système je ne
dis absolument rien sur la déontologie
qu'elle s'appliquera qui est
qui est celle qu'elle s'appliquera sur
le suivi de ce texte mais j'ai quand
même une sérieuse question démocratique
c'est à dire que sur le choix du
nucléaire en éclairant les arguments
est-ce que aujourd'hui le contexte ne
fait pas que c'est compliqué d'avoir un
vrai débat d'entendre des arguments de
manière rationnelle sur notre avenir
énergétique
alors je pense que ça jamais été simple
c'est que
moi quand j'étais au gouvernement
j'avais le sentiment parfois que dans le
regard de certains le fait d'être
anti-nucléaire
nuisait à la crédibilité ce que je
racontais c'est tout se passe comme si
vous êtes anti-nucléaire c'est forcément
suspect soit vous avez des intérêts
étrangers ça vous avez peur soit vous
êtes débile mental ou inculte alors que
le fait d'être trop nucléaire
enthousiaste ne pose pas problème c'est
considéré comme comme finalement assez
normal j'ai ça a toujours existé c'est
agaçant
ça a pris des formes différentes dans le
temps par exemple j'ai dû apporter ici
j'ai dû accorder ici un document
qui suit des travaux de l'Assemblée
nationale
en 2001
des députés déposent une proposition de
résolution pour créer une commission
d'enquête relative à l'existence et au
stockage de déchets nucléaires non
retraitébles à lag en violation de la
loi de décembre 91 la fameuse globale
c'est-à-dire que on ne peut pas garder
des déchets étrangers au-delà de
retraitement or il avait des quantités
énormes notamment des déchets allemands
qui par la suite ont été renvoyés et
donc c'est comme si on avait interdit
votre commission d'enquête au motifs que
votre attachement émotionnel au
nucléaire était insuffisant vous voyez
ce que je veux dire parce qu'en fait
l'argument pour rejeter l'argument
avant le vote c'est le président de la
Commission de la production des échanges
estime que le nucléaire est
indispensable à la couverture des
besoins énergies futurs de l'humanité
que les propositions formulées par les
parlementaires tente de manière
contournée et inavouée de remettre en
cause en son fondement même l'énergie
nucléaire dont il est irresponsable
d'envisager de se passer là on est dans
la foi on est dans la foi n'est pas dans
l'argumentation et donc je me suis dit
même à l'époque il y avait comme une
opinion critique sous nucléaire ou moi
au gouvernement j'ai pu exprimer une
position je pense que j'ose pas l'a dit
en gros moi j'ai pas mis mes convictions
dans ma poche après j'ai pas gagné je
considère que perdre c'est pas se battre
c'est pas ne pas avoir gagne cause mais
ne pas se battre donc je me suis battue
et puis je me suis dit que finalement
j'avais toujours aussi j'ai gagné des
choses sur la transparence sur la sûreté
sur la radioprotection sur la qualité du
dialogue qu'on avait avec les
entreprises
je pense d'ailleurs que j'ai gardé des
relations avec plusieurs de ces grands
dirigeants d'entreprises du nucléaire
qui dirait pas du mal de moi je pense
voilà
merci beaucoup madame Venet alors bon
je suis élu d'une circonscription qui a
comporté de réacteurs en fonctionnement
jusqu'à il y a 3 ans
j'assure encore la présidence de la
commission locale d'information et de
surveillance de l'INB de Fessenheim et
je dois vous confesser qu'à l'occasion
de la dernière visite que j'ai effectuée
sur le site pour
observer et constater le fonctionnement
du système qui visait à la
décontamination du circuit primaire
qu'un système inédit dans sa mise en
application technique en France
on était à l'approche de Noël et à
l'issue de la visite la directrice de la
centrale m'a offert une tartelette en
Alsace une tarte de Linz donc je la
déclarais à la déontologue pour être sûr
que tout cela ne constitue pas une
tentative de corruption de la part du
lobby nucléaire voilà en tout cas je
vous remercie pour ces 3 heures
d'audition
je constate madame la ministre que on
peut se nourrir du temps que nous
laissons à chacun pour s'exprimer sur le
sujet
et
voilà de l'espace que cela donne à
chacun quel que soit les points de vue
pour pouvoir éclairer l'histoire de la
stratégie énergétique sur les dernières
décennies pour notre pour notre état je
vous remercie et je vous souhaite une
bonne soirée
et je vous remercie pour votre écoute
merci